bon mes chers collègues je propose qu'on
commence
pour ce moment attendu parce qu'il y a
eu un certain un projet de loi de
finance rectificatif mais le premier
budget en tant que tel de la nation et
de ce mandat c'est aujourd'hui et donc
on a accueille Bruno Le Maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics sur le projet de loi
de finance pour 2023 ainsi que sur le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques chers
pour les années 2023 2028 adopté ce
matin en conseil des ministres avec
cette audition nous entamons l'examen
des textes budgétaires de l'automne avec
une séquence un peu exceptionnelle cette
année puisque comme vous le savez c'est
la première fois depuis que l'automne
depuis l'automne 2017 que le
gouvernement se livre un exercice de
programmation plus réel
la séquence est d'ailleurs
exceptionnelle à plus d'un titre puisque
c'est aussi cet automne que nous
ignorons inaugurons pardon la plupart
des innovations introduites par la
réforme de la LOLF promulguée le 28
décembre 2021 et au titre des
innovations méritant une notion
particulière on peut inciter la
présentation dans l'article linéaire des
prévisions de dépenses en volume et en
valeur pour l'ensemble des
administrations publiques et par sous
secteur la présence en première partie
d'un article
reconstant la liste exhaustive des taxes
affectées lors éventuelle plafond
d'affectation le fait que l'ensemble des
mesures fiscales quelle que soit l'année
de l'aurait fait sur le budget de l'État
figure en première partie la
présentation dans l'article d'équilibre
des ressources et des dépenses en
distinguant fonctionnement et
investissement de nouveaux États annexés
à la seconde partie l'un récapitulant
l'ensemble des moyens par mission du
budget général l'autre et numérant
l'intégralité des objectifs et
indicateurs de performance des missions
enfin même si ça se peut sembler plus
anecdotype l'accent la myotype pardon
l'absence d'impression des documents
budgétaires qui sont donc désormais
intégralement des matérialisés
concernant le calendrier d'examen des
textes sur les ministres nous présentent
aujourd'hui nous débuterons aux
commissions par l'examen du projet de
loi de programmation et de la première
partie du projet de loi de finances dès
le mardi 4 octobre nous poursuivons le
mercredi 6
5 pardon
et le jeudi 6 octobre délai de dépôt des
amendements et donc fixé au vendredi qui
précède à 17h ce qui laisse un peu plus
de 4 jours pour amender en vue de la
Commission en séance publique après une
discussion générale commune au projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques et au projet loi de finances
nous commencerons par examiner les
articles du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques dès
le lundi 10 octobre puis nous
poursuivrons avec l'examen de la
première partie du PLF la discussion de
la première partie devrait s'achever le
mercredi 19 octobre avec le débat sur le
prélèvement au profit de l'Union
européenne en vue d'un vote solennel sur
l'ensemble de la première partie qui
devrait avoir lieu le mardi 25 octobre
après les questions gouvernement vous
pouvez prendre des notes mais tout ça
vous sera rappelé évidemment par écrit
je crois même que ça déjà été fait en
même temps que le vote solennel sur le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques
je me permets d'utiliser le conditionnel
pour calendrier de la séance publique
car l'inverse du calendrier de la
commission ça dépendra aussi du Tour que
pendant les discussions et de ce que le
gouvernement pourrait décider de faire
la seule certitude que nous pouvons
avoir d'un point de vue procédural et
qu'il faut que la première partie du PLF
soit adoptée avant de pouvoir passer à
l'examen de la seconde partie l'examen
de la seconde partie en commission des
finances commencera donc justement le
mercredi 19 octobre jusqu'au mercredi 26
la Commission se saisira successivement
de toutes les missions qui seront à
l'ordre du jour de la séance publique à
compter du lundi jeudi
diable du jeudi 27 octobre et jusqu'au
jeudi 10 novembre il faudra également
examiner en commission les articles non
rattachés le mercredi 2 novembre
d'accord c'est bien mercredi bien en vue
d'un passage en Science Publique le
lundi 14 novembre le vote solennelle sur
l'ensemble du projet de finances pour
2023 intervient interviendrait donc sans
présager de ce que la tournure de la
discussion pourra donner le mardi 15
novembre monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics après cette introduction un peu
bourrative nous vous écoutons merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur
général
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver avec
Gabriel Attal pour présenter le premier
budget de ce nouveau quinquennat et le
sixième budget consécutif pour notre
majorité et votre serviteur
ce n'est pas un budget de rigueur
ce n'est pas un budget de facilité
c'est un budget responsable et
protecteur dans des temps de grande
incertitude
et c'est un budget qui veut tenir le
juste équilibre entre la protection
nécessaire de nos compatriotes et le
rétablissement indispensable les
finances publiques
c'est par ailleurs un budget qui tient
la ligne économique est toujours été la
nôtre depuis 2017 avec beaucoup de
Constance
le travail la rémunération du travail la
juste rémunération du travail la
croissance et l'investissement
ce budget je le disais il a été défini
dans une période de très forte
incertitude économique j'en suis très
que quelques-unes la poursuite de la
guerre en Ukraine évidemment avec son
issue incertaine qui a un impact majeur
sur les prix de l'énergie
les difficultés économiques de beaucoup
de nos partenaires économiques je pense
en particulier aux États-Unis à la Chine
avec sa stratégie et contre le covid ou
à l'Allemagne
je pense également au mouvement
politique en Europe et alors incident
éventuel sur la zone euro
dans ce contexte je tiens à rappeler la
résistance de l'économie française
nous avons indiqué que les 2,3% de
croissance en 2022 ne pourrait pas être
atteint nous avons aujourd'hui une
perspective de croissance à 2,7% pour
cette année 2022 nous avons une
consommation des ménages qui a rebondi
un emploi qui se tient des incessments
qui se maintiennent pour toutes ces
raisons et malgré toutes les
incertitudes que j'ai indiquées nous
maintenons une prévision de croissance
positive à 1% pour 2023
quelle est aujourd'hui notre priorité
absolue
notre priorité absolue celle dont vous
parle de compatriotes dans vos
circonscriptions celles dont on me parle
dans mes déplacements c'est l'inflation
l'inflation est une menace directe sur
les menaces sur les ménages les plus
fragiles
et une menace directe sur les classes
moyennes sur les retraités qui ne
peuvent pas augmenter leurs revenus
c'est un facteur de désorganisation des
chaînes de valeur qui peut obliger
certaines entreprises industrielles à
réduire leur production tout simplement
parce que la facture d'énergie est trop
élevée voit à délocaliser ils auront eu
l'occasion avec un certain nombre
d'entre vous vendredi dernier en
Haute-Savoie de vérifier à quel point
l'augmentation des prix d'énergie avait
un impact significatif sur les PME et
sur notre tissu industriel notre
priorité absolue je leur ai dit donc est
de faire reculer une inflation qui
restera un niveau élevé dans les mois
qui viennent de l'ordre de 6% avant de
revenir autour de 4% dans le courant de
l'année 2023
comment est-ce que nous comptons nous y
employer
d'abord en maintenant un bouclier
énergétique qui est la singularité de la
politique économique française nous
sommes le seul pays dans la zone euro
avoir adopté dès l'automne 2021 sur la
proposition du Président de la
République un bouclier énergétique qui a
maintenu les prix de l'électricité et
les prix du gaz à des niveaux
raisonnables
le résultat c'est que nous avons le taux
d'inflation le plus faible de la zone
euro et que nous n'atteignons pas les 8
9 10 11% 12% d'inflation que connaissent
aujourd'hui certains États membres de la
zone euro
nous avons donc pris la décision de
maintenir ce bouclier énergétique les
prix du gaz et de l'électricité
augmenteront c'est vrai
mais augmenteront de 15% au début de
l'année 2023 alors qu'ils auraient dû
augmenter de plus de 100 %
. nous maintenons donc cette protection
qui est à la fois juste pour les ménages
et efficace pour notre économie
le coup net de ce bouclier de 16
milliards d'euros 11 pour le bouclier
gaz 5 pour le bouclier électricité mais
ce coût serait de plus de triple si nous
n'avions pas déjà en place un mécanisme
de redistribution des rentes des
énergéticiens et je veux le dire dans le
débat que nous aurons évidemment sur la
situation de certaines entreprises nous
ne voulons pas de nouveaux impôts mais
nous refusons catégoriquement les rentes
et donc des énergéticiens qui touchent
des revenus exceptionnels non pas parce
qu'ils ont investi mais uniquement parce
que les prix flambes doivent reverser
ces bénéfices à la collectivité et
reverse déjà ses bénéfices à la
collectivité c'est ce qui nous permet de
financer le bouclier énergétique que je
ne veux laisser aucun doute là-dessus
nous ne sommes pas pour le laisser faire
laisser aller nous ne sommes pas pour
des impôts supplémentaires nous sommes
contre les rentes et nous récupérons le
produit des rentes notamment des
énergéticiens pour financer notre
bouclier énergétique et je me réjouis
que la Commission européenne est repris
à son compte ce mécanisme preuve de sa
justice et de son efficacité
protéger nos compatriotes contre
l'inflation c'est également protéger
tous ceux qui travaillent
et tous ceux qui paient des impôts
nous avons pris la décision d'indexer le
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu sur le
niveau d'inflation hors tabac soit 5,4%.
je rappelle que nous aurions pu indexer
le barème de lierre sur les salaires
nous avons fait un autre choix et nous
le revendiquons nous avons évité à tous
ceux qui sont soumis à l'impôt sur le
revenu de payer davantage d'impôts
c'est le sens de ce choix
stratégique qui a été fait avec le
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu ça veut
dire très concrètement que le revenu
disponible après un pot restera le même
pour tous les ménages même s'il s'avère
augmente
ceux qui travaillent sont donc
récompensés de leur travail et n'en sont
pas privés par l'inflation
nous voulons également protéger des
entreprises et là aussi c'est d'une
grande constance par rapport à la
stratégie qui a toujours été la nôtre
nous avons refusé que la crise du covid
et que la récession brutale qui a suivi
la crise du covid n'emporte des pans
entiers de l'économie française et de
conduisent à des dizaines de milliers de
faillites nous voulons pas que ce qui
n'est pas arrivé pendant la crise du
covid arrive en raison de l'inflation et
nous voulons protéger notre tissu
industriel contre les ravages de la
flambée des prix de l'électricité et les
prix du gaz
pour les plus petites entreprises celles
qui ont un chiffre d'affaires inférieur
à 2 millions d'euros et qui ont moins de
10 salariés elles sont protégées par les
tarifs régulés de vente avec une hausse
qui sera limitée à 15%
. pour toutes les autres entreprises
nous mettrons en place un guichet
simplifié pour des aides jusqu'à hauteur
de 2 millions d'euros qui sera
opérationnel le 3 octobre le précédent
n'a pas fonctionné nous l'avons donc
corrigé et simplifier
nous avons notamment retenu comme
critères le fait d'avoir des bénéfices
en baisse sur un mois au lieu des trois
mois précédents et simplifie également
le critère de chiffre d'affaires
reste la question des entreprises qui
sont exposées à la concurrence
internationale et qui ont des factures
d'énergie particulièrement élevées là
encore je reprends l'exemple des
décolleters de la vallée de l'arbre qui
produisent des pièces de moteur
automobile par exemple s'ils vont sur un
marché chinois sur un marché américain
et qu'ils expliquent qu'ils ont dû faire
passer des hausses de 5 10 15 20% à
cause des prix de l'électricité mais le
marché chinois le marché américain leur
dit mais désolé il n'y a pas
d'augmentation des prix d'énergie donc
on ne voit pas pour qu'on paierait plus
cher
donc c'est bien ces entreprises là qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie et qui
sont exposés à la concurrence
internationale donc ils ne peuvent pas
répercuter sur le prix qu'il faut
protéger en priorité absolue
j'ai fait des propositions à la
Commission européenne de simplification
du dispositif existant qui est
insuffisant et trop complexe
j'ai demandé d'une part que le critère
de la part de l'énergie dans le chiffre
d'affaires qui est actuellement de 3%
soit ABC
j'ai demandé qu'il soit calculé non pas
sur l'année précédant l'année 2022 mais
durant l'année
parce que vous avez des entreprises qui
ont une part de l'énergie dans leur
chiffre d'affaires qui peut représenter
un ou deux pour cent en 2021
mais en 2022 ça représentera 5 ou 6%
elles ne sont pas éligibles
donc il faut modifier ses règles de
calcul en ajustant le calcul sur l'année
N et pas sur l'année N-
j'ai également demandé que le critère
débiteda en baisse sur trois mois soit
supprimé ça n'a aucun sens dans
l'entreprise industrielle d'attendre que
les bits soient négatifs sur trois mois
au bout d'un mois en général
l'entreprise industrielle se retrouve
déjà dans de très grandes difficultés
nous retiendrons donc comme critère
unique la baisse des bénéfices sur un
mois enfin j'ai demandé que le plafond
des aides soit doublé qu'il passe de 25
à 50 millions d'euros et pour le plafond
à 50 de 50 à 100 millions d'euros de
façon à porter les sommes nécessaires
pour les entreprises qui en ont le plus
besoin et quand les factures d'énergie
les plus importantes nous aurons les
réponses de la Commission européenne
dans les prochains jours je peux déjà
vous dire que les modifications de ces
règles dettes d'État qui devint
intervenir le 1er janvier 2023 grâce à
l'intervention de la France
interviendront en octobre de cette année
dans ce budget nous poursuivons aussi la
transformation de notre économie pour
atteindre des objectifs stratégiques que
nous nous sommes fixés avec le président
de la République et la première ministre
le plein emploi en 2027 et le passage
sous les 3% de déficits publics pour
cela notre stratégie reste la même
le soutien à la croissance la réduction
des dépenses et les réformes de
structure
le soutien à la croissance il se voit et
il se lit dans la baisse des impôts de
production que nous continuons à porter
qui la traduction d'une politique de
l'offre qui vise tout simplement à
permettre à notre tissu économique et
notamment notre tissu industriel de se
développer nous sommes la seule majorité
depuis 25 ans avoir engagé la baisse des
impôts de production et je considère que
cette baisse est indispensable pour
accélérer la reconquête industrielle de
la nation française vous ne pouvez pas
garantir la reconquête industrielle du
pays quand les industries sont lestées
d'un tel boulet au pied nous avons
réduit de 10 milliards d'euros nous les
réduirons à nouveau de 8 milliards
d'euros mais nous le ferons pour tenir
compte de la situation des finances
publiques en deux fois sur 2023 et sur
2024 et nous vous proposons pour
garantir que la parole soit tenue
d'inscrire cette trajectoire sur deux
ans dans le PLF 2023
pour soutenir la croissance nous nous
appuierons évidemment aussi sur
l'innovation notamment sur France 2030
nous avons inscrit 6 milliards d'euros
d'engagement dans le budget 2023 et nous
veillons à ce que tout cet environnement
plus favorable tout se financement de
l'innovation se traduisent bien
concrètement par des décisions de
relocalisation de production
industrielle de sites industriels de
chaîne de valeur dans notre pays c'est
ce que nous avons fait avec global
findrise sur les semi-conducteurs avec
STMicro acroll et c'est ce que nous
voulons obtenir de l'industrie
automobile ou d'autres secteurs
industriels
le deuxième volet de cette stratégie de
rétablissement des finances publiques
c'est évidemment la réduction des
dépenses
le quoi qu'il en coûte
était la bonne réponse face à
l'effondrement notre économie
il nous a évité des dizaines de milliers
de faillites une explosion du chômage et
au bout du compte il a été moins coûteux
que les dépenses qui ont été nécessaires
pour réparer une crise économique
majeure
mais quoi qu'il en coûte serait une
faute économique en période d'inflation
nous avons mis fin pourquoi qu'il en
coûte nous ne rétablirons pas le quoi
qu'il en coûte et je ne veux laisser
aucune ambiguïté là-dessus rétablir le
quoiqu'il en coûte c'est tout simplement
alimenter l'incendie inflationniste
c'est au contraire des aides ciblées
qu'il faut mettre en place sur les
secteurs des personnes les industries
les entreprises qui en ont le plus
besoin nous avons donc mis fin au crédit
de relance nous avons mis fin au
dispositif d'urgence je sais qu'il y a
parfois des demandes pour rétablir des
dispositifs globaux de ce type là ne le
feront pas car ce serait une faute
économique par ailleurs Gabriel Attal
aura l'occasion d'y revenir les dépenses
publiques leur progression restera
inférieure au rythme de l'inflation
preuve de notre détermination à contenir
l'augmentation de la dépense publique
enfin je veux là aussi être très clair
sur le sujet nous ne pourrons pas
rétablir nos finances publiques baisser
la dette réduire les déficits si en plus
de la croissance
en plus de la réduction des dépenses
nous n'engageons pas des transformations
structurelles qui sont je crois au cœur
de ce que notre majorité a promis au
peuple français
nous poursuivrons donc la réforme de
l'assurance chômage un moment où vous
avez près de 400 000 emplois qui ne sont
pas pourvus et nous engagerons une
réforme des retraites
cette réforme des retraites nous ne
faisons pas pour le plaisir de faire une
réforme des retraites le faisons d'abord
parce que elle a été promise par le
Président de la République
lors de sa campagne présidentielle
et qu'elle fait donc partie du mandat
qui a été confiée par le peuple français
au président de la République et à cette
majorité et que j'ai toujours été
convaincu qu'il valait mieux en matière
politique tenir ses promesses et que six
mois après les élections
dire que nous pourrions abandonner une
promesse de campagne centrale sur
laquelle il y a eu un débat il y a eu
des échanges il y a eu parfois des
controverses parfois des critiques mais
ce débat était tranché tranché par le
peuple souverain qui s'est prononcé en
faveur d'un candidat qui proposait une
réforme des retraites avec une
modification de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite et des critères de calcul de
cette retraite
et bien j'ai la conviction qu'il vaut
mieux tenir parole en matière politique
j'ai également la conviction que si nous
voulons financer notre modèle de
solidarité il y a deux voies qui se
présentent devant nous
parce que ce modèle est généreux
efficace ou ils sont tous attachés mais
les coûteux donc il faut bien le payer
vous avez deux manières de le payer soit
vous augmentez les impôts
ça n'a jamais été la voix de la majorité
soit vous dégagez plus de recettes plus
de prospérité plus de travail c'est
notre voix et c'est celle qui amène une
réforme des retraites enfin je suis
convaincu pour en finir sur mes
convictions sur ce sujet que vous
connaissez déjà que l'on peut faire une
réforme juste
responsable dans des délais raisonnables
tout en arrivant à obtenir l'adhésion de
nos compatriotes
enfin ce budget reste fidèle à notre
détermination à accélérer la transition
écologique et accélérer la transition
énergétique je vais être honnête comme à
chaque fois avec vous nous pourrions
certainement faire mieux et il est
évident que le budget est un peu déporté
dans un sens qui n'est pas celui que
nous aurions souhaité
par les aides et les subventions à nos
compatriotes en matière de gaz et en
2022 en matière de carburant
nous l'admettons nous le reconnaissons
et je pense que c'était une nécessité
face à la crise de l'inflation pour
autant je voudrais souligner un certain
nombre de décisions qui sont dans ce
budget et qui sont importantes pour
accélérer le verdissement et je pense
que nous devons faire plus et faire
mieux dans les mois qui viennent le
budget de ma prime rénov va passer de 2
milliards d'euros en 2022 à 2,5
milliards d'euros en 2023 c'est une
augmentation très significative et comme
cela est apparu pendant un dialogue de
Bercy qui avait lancé le ministre des
comptes publics nous devons travailler
ensemble et une amélioration de
l'efficacité de ce dispositif en passant
de rénovation par gestes individuel
adhérer
je pense que ça peut être un des débats
intéressants de ce PLF 2023
nous mettrons en place 1,3 milliards
d'euros pour le verdissement du parc
automobile nous accélèrerons donc la
transformation de ce parc nous mettrons
en place un fond vert doté de 1,5
milliards d'euros créé à la demande de
la première ministre pour les
collectivités territoriales enfin je
tiens assister sur le fait que nous
amorçons un virage radical en matière de
garantie export pour la première fois de
son histoire la France n'accordera plus
aucune garantie export pour aucune
énergie fossile depuis l'exploration
jusqu'au raffinage en passant par le
transport c'est un choix radical que
nous avons fait dans ce domaine
je termine enfin par les éléments de
finance publique pour rappeler que notre
objectif en 2023 et bien de tenir les 5%
de déficit public et de ramener la dette
un peu plus de 111% en fin d'année tout
cela demandera de la fermeté tout cela
demandera de la constance tout ça
demandera aussi de l'imagination et je
remercie Daniel Labaronne et les
parlementaires qui ont travaillé avec
lui sur un centre de proposition pour
réduire la dépense publique toutes ces
propositions qui nous permettront de
respecter nos engagements nationaux et
nos engagements européens seront les
bienvenus
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget très
rapidement en complément de ce qu'est
indiqué Bruno Le Maire Bruno Le Maire a
rappelé les aléas auxquels nous faisons
face d'un point de vue géopolitique d'un
point de vue économique et si on ne peut
pas faire de politique avec une boule de
cristal on peut faire de la politique
avec une boussole et notre boussole ça a
été depuis le début de cette crise ou de
ces crises et ça restera la protection
des Français et le budget que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui est un budget de
protection nous avons plusieurs
objectifs le premier c'est de protéger
les Français pour répondre à l'urgence
de la fin du mois je ne reviens pas sur
le bouclier tarifaire qui a été rappelé
par Bruno Le Maire qui constitue une des
dépenses conséquentes de ce budget 2023
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu et tu mesure forte de protection
du pouvoir d'achat des Français je veux
insister sur ce point
j'ai entendu parfois dans le débat
certains dire oui mais c'était une
mesure automatique qui a lieu chaque
année d'abord ça n'a pas eu lieu chaque
année il y a des années où le barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu n'a pas été indexé
sur l'inflation je pense notamment aux
revenus de 2011 et de 2012 donc déjà des
majorités avaient fait le choix de ne
pas indexer le barème de l'inflation
ensuite quand on est un tel niveau
d'inflation qu'on venait que la question
peut se poser en raison de ce que cela
implique en terme de budget pour nos
finances publiques très concrètement
c'est donc plus de 6 milliards d'euros
j'avais annoncé 6,2 milliards en réalité
réévaluer ces 6,4 milliards d'euros
d'impôt sur le revenu qui aura été
prélevé sur les Français qui ne le
seront pas par cette décision le
deuxième axe c'est protéger les Français
en poursuivant le réarmement de nos
services régaliens 3 milliards en plus
pour la défense conformément la
programmation militaire un milliard 400
millions d'euros en plus pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur conformément à
la trajectoire de la locmi c'est plus de
un moyen plus de moyens pour les
équipements les technologies numériques
pour renforcer la présence de policiers
et de gendarmes sur la voie publique
plus de moyens pour nos douanes vous
savez que j'y suis très attaché étant le
ministre des douaniers 144 millions en
plus pour les douaniers sur la période
2022 2025 pour renforcer les équipements
mobiles améliorer notre flotte aérienne
et navale enfin nous poursuivons le
renforcement des moyens du ministère de
la Justice avec une hausse de 8% pour la
troisième année consécutive le troisième
axe c'est protéger les Français en
préparant l'avenir c'est faire le pari
de l'éducation c'est gagner la bataille
du plein emploi c'est accélérer la
transition écologique le budget prévoit
ainsi une augmentation de 3,7 milliards
d'euros pour l'éducation comme nous y
étions engagés dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle aucun enseignant
ne gagnera moins de 2000 euros net par
mois à compter de la rentrée prochaine
gagner la bataille du plein emploi c'est
l'objectif que nous avons fixé à
horizons 2027 ce sont ainsi 6,7
milliards d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires investis pour l'emploi
pour l'apprentissage pour atteindre un
million d'apprentis d'ici 2027 et je le
dis clairement Bruno Le Maire a rappelé
nous ne gagnerons pas la bataille du
plein emploi avec davantage de pression
fiscale c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons d'ores et déjà rendu 54
milliards d'euros au ménage et aux
entreprises au cours des cinq dernières
années et nous allons continuer à
baisser les impôts lorsqu'ils sont
néfastes pour le développement
économique de notre pays avec la
suppression de la CVAE enfin préparé
l'avenir c'est protéger la planète il
nous agissons vous le savez de manière
résolue en ce sens c'est le fond à un
milliard 5 annoncé par la première
ministre c'est 500 millions d'euros en
plus sur ma prime rénov c'est 250
millions d'euros en plus pour le plan
vélo
le quatrième axe c'est protégé nos
comptes publics et je veux le dire et le
réaffirmer nous sommes sortis du
quoiqu'il en coûte et nous sommes dans
le combien ça coûte 1 € dépensé est un
euro raisonné un euro évalué 1 euro
utile à la protection des Français nous
avons un cadre qui est la trajectoire
qui a été fixé dans le cadre du
programme de stabilité nous tiendrons
notre objectif de 5% de déficit l'an
prochain après l'avoir tenu cette année
et je rappelle que le déficit était de
près de 9% en 2020 que nous l'avons
descendu à 6,4% en 2021 il est de 5%
cette année sera de 5% l'an prochain et
nous serons revenus sous les 3% en 2027
comme on va faire Bruno Le Maire l'a
rappelé en suscitant l'activité
économique par des réformes ambitieuses
pour améliorer l'emploi dans notre pays
plus il y a de Français qui travaillent
plus il y a de recettes parce qu'il y a
des cotisations parce qu'il y a une
activité économique qui se développe et
moi évidemment il y a des dépenses de
réparation pour accompagner des Français
qui ne travaillent pas
et ensuite en maîtrisant la dépense
publique nous maîtrisons la progression
de la dépense publique elle baisse de
2,6% en volume en 2023 par rapport à
2022 la part des dépenses publiques
rapportées au PIB diminue elle passe de
57,6 % du PIB cette année à 56,6% du PIB
l'an prochain elle passera à 53,8% du
PIB en 2027
nous poursuivons par ailleurs le travail
d'évaluation de la qualité de la dépense
publique et je veux insister sur la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui est présentée qui prévoit pour cela
des outils supplémentaires je veux
notamment mentionner l'article 7 de ce
projet de loi de programmation qui
systématise les évaluations des dépenses
fiscales avant de décider d'un éventuel
d'une éventuelle reconduction c'est un
outil dont le Parlement doit pleinement
se saisir car évidemment nous sommes
tous responsables de nos finances
publiques et tous les dispositifs de
dépenses fiscale doivent pouvoir être
évalués et ensuite le Parlement
souverainement doit décider s'ils sont
reconduits ou pas répondre à l'urgence
financer l'essentiel préparer l'avenir
et tenir les comptes voilà les quatre
axes qui structurent notre action voilà
la stratégie que nous vous proposons
pour protéger les Français dans cette
période exceptionnelle nous avons
parfaitement conscience que les défis
sont immenses et c'est précisément parce
que les défis sont immenses que nous
devons inventer ensemble une nouvelle
méthode c'est ce que nous avons voulu
faire avec Bruno Le Maire en lançant les
dialogues de aussi nous verrons dans les
prochaines semaines si les pistes que
nous avons dessiné ensemble permettent
d'enrichir le texte je veux dire que je
ne minimise en rien les désaccords que
nous avons sur le fond évidemment il y
aura toujours ceux qui veulent augmenter
les impôts et ceux qui veulent les
baisser et sur un certain nombre de
points absolument structurants il y a
des désaccords de fonds mais ce n'est
pas parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur
tout qu'on ne peut discuter de rien et
je crois que le travail que nous avons
eu ces dernières semaines une grande
partie d'entre vous était présent dans
cette plus d'une dizaine d'heures de
réunions qui se sont tenus à montrer que
nous étions capables de nous parler de
travailler ensemble d'identifier des
propositions des solutions au service
des Français et le texte qui vous est
présenté aujourd'hui n'est pas le même
que celui qui avait été prévu avant le
lancement des dialogues de Bercy et il
continuera à être enrichi ensuite de par
les travaux que nous aurons ensemble il
y a tout un paquet de mesures qui ont
été imaginés suite aux échanges que nous
avons eu ces suite aux échanges que nous
avons eu que nous avons décidé
de suspendre l'application de
l'actualisation des bases locatives qui
étaient critiqués de toutes parts et
c'est à la suite de nos échanges que
nous l'avons suspendu ces suites à nos
échanges que nous avons accepté de
renforcer plus encore que prévu les
crédits ma prime rénove mais que nous
avons aussi engagé un travail pour
revoir le barème de ma prime rénov pour
soutenir davantage les rénovations
globales et les travaux vont se
poursuivre sur ce sujet là c'est suite à
nos échanges que nous avons enrichi le
paquet collectivité locale qui était
prévue au départ avec notamment la
suppression de la CVAE en deux fois la
compensation par une fraction de TVA et
nous avons annoncé avec Caroline
cailleux devant le Comité des finances
locales où j'étais il y a quelques
instants une partie d'entre vous était
également présent que nous allions
renforcer les dotations de péréquation
dans la DGF l'an prochain à hauteur de
210 millions d'euros c'était aussi une
proposition je salue notamment Christine
Pirès bonne qui avait été émise dans le
cadre des dialogues de Bercy nous
l'avons retenu ça veut dire qu'en plus
d'une des GF
au niveau national comme nous l'avons
garanti depuis cinq ans nous
garantissons une stabilité de la DGF
c’était aussi un point qui a été soulevé
et soutenu par Jean-René Cazeneuve pour
les collectivités au niveau individuel
via un abondement des dotations de
péréquation pour que la péréquation ne
se fasse plus sur le dos entre
guillemets de la dotation forfaitaire et
donc de collectivités locales on voit
donc que des avancées sont possibles et
le souhait que je formule que nous
formulons avec Bruno Le Maire c'est
évidemment de poursuivre un travail le
plus partenariat possible au service de
la protection de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
bien messieurs les ministres merci
je vais ouvrir le bal avant de passer la
parole au rapporteur général et puis au
représentants des groupes juste bon
quelques réflexions par rapport à ce
projet de loi de finance qui qui m'est
arrivé ce matin comme à la plupart
d'entre vous donc sans être exhaustif le
premier constat que je voulais faire
c'était
celui du contexte dans lequel on est et
quand même du rappel de ce qui avait pu
être dit pendant le programme de
stabilité lors de la discussion sur le
drame de stabilité nous avons été
quelques-uns à pointer ce que nous
considérions alors comme des prévisions
optimistes du gouvernement Bruno Le
Maire avait dit on est dans le pic ça a
duré encore quelques semaines voire
quelques mois forcer de constater
aujourd'hui le gouvernement l'admet que
les prévisions économiques en termes de
croissance qu'en termes d'inflammation
d'un fleuve inflation pardon mais c'est
un rapport était avec le réchauffement
climatique ça rapporte était
optimiste évidemment ça a des
conséquences alors première
interrogation enfin qui n'est pas
vraiment une mais qui même s'il Gabriel
a eu l'honnêteté de dire où Bruno Le
Maire je sais pas vous les deux qu'on
était dans une situation économique très
instable et très incertaine c'est que 1%
de croissance annoncé au lieu du 1 4
pour 2023 qui a évidemment des
conséquences j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure et paraît par exemple optimisme
par rapport aux prévisions de la Banque
de France qui est entre plus 0,8 et voir
un risque de récession à -05 bon et de
même l'inflation qui cette fois-ci a été
réévaluée à 4,2 au lieu de mémoire de
mémoire 3,4 je crois lors de la du
programme de stabilité la Banque de
France voit un minimum de 4,7 voire
pouvant monter jusqu'à 6 9 donc moi je
crois qu'on encore par rapport au
contexte il nous donnait notamment avec
l'objectif d'atteindre les 5% de déficit
dans des prévisions qui qui me semblent
tout aussi optimiste que celle que je
faisais en juillet dernier et si je dis
ça c'est pas pour plaisir de les faire
c'est par rapport à la conjoncturation
nationale est-ce que ça peut entraîner
deuxième constat
vous aviez annoncé une augmentation des
dépenses publiques de
0,6%, ce qui par rapport au niveau de
croissance tendancielle des dépenses
publiques qui selon Bercy et de 1-35
c'est-à-dire ce qu'il faudrait comme
niveau de dépenses publiques pour
correspondre aux besoins de la
population à l'augmentation de la
population vous a dit annoncé 06
et nous avions et je continue à le dire
pointer du doigt le fait que ça serait
une cure de stérilité pour les dépenses
publiques assez inédites dans la
cinquième république si mes calculs sont
bons par rapport au 21,7 que vous
annoncez ce matin
dont j'aimerais d'ailleurs avoir le
détail parce que les 21 sur le tableau
des dépenses de l'étage arrive à 14,5 et
je vois que vous mettez 21,7 alors je
sais pas si ça tient compte du déficit
également du PLFSS enfin je voudrais
bien en détail mais prenons le 21/7
annoncé on se rend compte que si on
tient compte d'une inflation à 5,2 on en
est 1% de de croissance publique bon
donc on est en dessous de la croissance
ancienne mais pas sur les 06 si on tient
compte par contre des chiffres de
l'inflation de la Banque de France on
est au 05 et là on est dans une
situation encore plus compliquée
pourquoi je dis ça parce que
j'observe que les les si vous si vous ne
vous ne baissez pas autant les dépenses
publiques mais ça a confirmé que ce que
vous annonciez cet été
vous garantissez vous vous revendiquez
encore du maîtrise dépense publique moi
je ne suis pas d'accord je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises Bruno Le Maire alors
peut-être que ça dépend de la définition
on a du quoi qu'il en coûte je pense pas
que le quoi qu'il en coûte soit derrière
nous je pense qu'il change de nature je
pense qu'il peut être par exemple un
quoiqu'il en coûte pour faire face à la
détérioration du au réchauffement
climatique comme on l'a vu cet été et
dans ces cas-là le quoi qu'il en coûte
qui était celui mis en place pour faire
face au covid pour être dupliquer pour
faire face aux incendies qui se
multiplient à la sécheresse au
changement météo etc je ne crois pas que
le quoi qu'il en coûte
provoqué par la situation de guerre en
Ukraine soit vraiment derrière nous
autrement dit j'ai pour ma part je pense
que votre budget ne prend pas assez en
compte les besoins qui sont ceux de la
population de l'intérêt général
notamment en termes écologique et social
et du fait justement de d'avoir d'autres
visées vous l'avez dit la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques la question de de
baisse des impôts et bien finalement
laisse de côté à mon avis certaines
choses auxquelles il faut répondre en
urgence je vous donne un exemple le
pouvoir d'achat
si on en croit rexicode qui pense qu'il
baissera de 20% l'an prochain et même si
on en croit de la Banque de France qui
prévoit une stabilité non pas
d'augmentation je ne pense pas que les
mesures soient aujourd'hui de
suffisante notamment pour les
populations les plus défavorisées pour
maintenir un pouvoir d'achat qui je
rappelle c'est aussi de manière de
maintenir la consommation populaire et
donc d'avoir des retombées pour
l'économie de la même manière je ne
pense pas au niveau écologique que ce
soit à travers ma prime rénov ou les
dispositifs qui soient proposés que on
soit à la hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait
faire en matière de bifurcation on a eu
ce débat d'ailleurs intéressant Bruno Le
Maire et je crois que vous en aviez
convenu la réponse de ma collègue et va
SAS pendant les dialogues de Bercy
est-ce que ma prime rénove c'est-à-dire
de la rénovation partielle est à la
hauteur du du nombre de rénovations
complètes qu'il faut faire chaque année
d'isolation pour répondre à la
bifurcation je ne crois pas et là on
voit bien que du coup c'est un budget
qui ne ne correspond pas pour ma part
aux urgences je n'irai pas plus loin là
dessus on y reviendra pour le débat
troisième chose s'il y a urgence c'est
qu'il faut dire 7 supplémentaires et là
j'ai entendu ce matin Bruno Le Maire
vous avez dit en gros hein pas de
dépenses en plus sans recettes à l'eau
près donc là ouvre je trouve un débat
sur les baisses de dépens de baisse de
recettes que l'État se propose
d'appliquer pour se PLF bon il y en a
une première c'est le fait que vous
maintenez la part la part du CVAE de 4
milliards bon vous avez dit c'est il
faut lever le le boulet que se traîne
les entreprises moi je rappelle que le
CVAE il a deux défauts la première c'est
qu'il accroît les inégalités de la
fiscalité des entreprises puisque les
deux tiers du CVAE bénéficient aux 10000
plus grosses entreprises françaises
voilà une entreprise par exemple qui à 2
millions de chiffre d'affaires 550 000
euros de valeur ajoutée paye 825 euros
seulement de CVAE chaque année
plus vous êtes gros plus en profiter par
contre pour les collectivités c'est un
problème parce que c'est remplacé par
des impôts plus injustes la TVA qui est
un impôt évidemment non proportionnel
mais on voit aussi l'augmentation des
taxes foncières qui est à taux uniques
contrairement à la question du donc
première chose je pense que il doit
s'engager un débat parce qu'on a besoin
de recette et que c'est pas une bonne
façon de baisser à mon avis les impôts
sur cette question la deuxième c'est
est-ce qu'il était urgent je sais que ça
avait été décidé mais de baisser la taxe
d'habitation cette année pour les 20%
des ménages les plus favorisés quand on
a besoin de recettes
j'interroge sur cette question et à
contrario j'observe que
ce qui nous avait été ce que moi j'avais
cru comprendre des dialogues de Bercy
c'est à dire le fait de toucher à des
niches fiscales qui n'ont pas de
rentabilité qui sont des dépenses
fiscales importantes si je regarde le
projet de loi de finance
j'ai vu les quelques niches fiscales qui
sont proposées des supprimer on n'est
pas à mon avis au nous disons jeux
notamment sur une révision qui pourrait
être celui d'un crédit pour recherche
vous avez parlé il y a la débat qui
s'engagera sur les taxes des super
profits j'ai noté vous avez répété Bruno
Le Maire exactement ce que nous aviez
dit avec j'enregistre avec plaisir
pendant les dialogues de Bercy
c'est-à-dire que la question de la rente
ou l'avait dit et critiquable à partir
du moment les niveaux bien trop
important par rapport à une situation
normale mais sauf que j'interroge le
fait de se contenter qu'elle soit
appliquée aux énergéticiens il me semble
qu'il y a d'autres entreprises et on l'a
pointé avec certains groupes dans la
proposition qu'on fait de référendum
d'initiative partagée il y a deux
entreprises qui ont bénéficier de la
même manière et qui développent une
rente notamment versée en dividende qui
devrait à mon avis est une piste de
travail d'autant plus que on le sait les
uns et les autres on a on va avoir du
mal à attaquer entre guillemets les
taxes d'un seul secteur ce qui pourrait
être anticonstit je terminerai sur juste
un point la retraite la question des
retraites que vous avez
vous avez souligné bon on verra cette
semaine ce qu'il en est j'espère très
franchement que le gouvernement n'aura
pas l'idée de mettre la réforme des
retraites à travers un amendement du
PLFSS je pense même que si j'avais un
conseil à lui donner
ça serait de de surseoir à ça à la fois
pour des questions de majorité à
l'Assemblée mais aussi de mouvement
social mais moi je voulais examine
aborder cette question sous un autre
angle parce que j'ai entendu dans le
interview du JDD et Gabriel Attal
expliqué que c'était une manière de
baisser les déficits et également les
déficits et de par exemple de permettre
que on puisse envisager des dépenses
pour les enseignants etc moi je suis
assez étonné que en réalité on a épuisé
sur les les budgets le budget du PLFSS
et notamment la question des retraites
qui devrait s'équilibrer entre qui
devrait être une question de cotisation
du d'un côté et de l'autre côté de
s'assurer que les retrait
les Français puissent en bénéficier
qu'on fasse jouer un autre rôle en
réalité à cette question je pense que
c'est de plus en plus souvent où on fait
jouer à notre rôle à la question des
budgets sociaux mais là en l'occurrence
je suis désolé on peut avoir un débat
sur qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour les
retraites on va chercher l'argent pour
faire en sorte que les gens partent
toujours à un âge décent à la retraite
mais je ne vois pas en quoi c'est tout
retraite de compenser les déficits de
l'État c'est un autre débat voilà je
vais m'arrêter là pour l'instant merci
et je passe la parole à jean-rodicace
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues en 2020
nous avions un budget du quoi qu'il en
coûte pour faire face à une crise
inédite en 2021 nous avions un budget de
relance aujourd'hui pour présenter un
budget qu'on pourrait qualifier de
protecteur et volontariste en effet les
textes que vous présentez trace 4 axes
qui ensemble définissent et traduisent
la politique budgétaire et économique de
notre majorité je vais revenir
rapidement parce que vous les avez déjà
évoqué le premier objectif est
précisément cette protection le soutien
constant apporté aux français durant
cette crise dès la fin de l'année 2021
fortement en 2022 j'y reviens pas à les
aides directes le bouclier tarifel la
reverraction des prestations sociales du
point nadis etc vous proposez notamment
la poursuite du bouclier tarifaire en
2023 en le compétant les cacher
qu'énergie ciblant les ménages les plus
fragiles et vous proposez également de
rendre 6,4 milliards d'euros au ménage
en revalorisant le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu
le deuxième objectif est de poursuivre
notre politique de l'offre en faisant
une nouvelle baisse des impôts de
production en faveur de la tractivité de
notre pays et du plan d'emploi en deux
ans nous rendons plus de 6 milliards
d'euros à nos entreprises notamment
industrielles dans la continuité d'une
politique et efficace depuis 2017 il
faut le redire enfin notre pays notre
transe est devenue et redevenue
attractive elle attire de nouveau les
investissements de nouveau les emplois
industriels c'est aussi un pays où le
chômage a refluer j'appartiens à une
génération qui depuis qu'elle est jeune
entend parler d'un chômage endémique
nous n'en sommes plus là aujourd'hui
voir c'est une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
à laquelle nous devons faire face alors
oui nous pensons que collectivement nous
devons travailler plus pour sauvegarder
nos systèmes de retraite par répartition
et générer de nouvelles marges de
manoeuvre pour financer de nouvelles
politiques publiques et ce ici qui
Stig franchise les entreprises dénigre
la valeur travail voire pour certains
font l'apologie de la paresse porte une
lourde responsabilité le troisième
objectif est la poursuite de l'effort de
financement de nos politiques
prioritaires en premier lieu le
gouvernement propose
il se sont reconnus ils se sont reconnus
en premier lieu le mouvement le
gouvernement propose de majorer dépenses
publiques relatives à l'éducation et à
la formation rémunération des
enseignants financement de
l'apprentissage et de la formation
continue ensuite il s'agit de ne rien
lâcher en matière de transition
écologique et énergétique et je suis
d'accord nous n'en ferons jamais assez
en la matière c'est le sens des
ouvertures de crédit relatif à ma prise
rénove et au plan d'investissement pour
la France de 2030 c'est aussi le choix
du réarmement régalien en faveur de nos
armées et de nos forces de l'ordre le
quatrième objectif
et l'engagement d'une trajectoire
soutenable pour nos finances publiques
c'est l'objectif du pélèbre mais aussi
et surtout du projet de loi de
programmation des finances il faut un
moyen terme engager notre désendettement
et cela passe par une trajectoire
crédible et raisonnable en dépense et ne
déficit maîtriser en dessous de 3% de
notre richesse nationale en 2027 il
faudra du courage et de la pédagogie car
il faudra des réformes un coup d'oeil
chez nos voisins le montrait aimant la
trajectoire proposée est très loin de
l'austérité tout comme on est loin
également d'une politique budgétaire
sans cape et sans maîtrise soyons
collectivement responsables de cette
ligne de crête qu'il nous faut suivre
absolument mais question messieurs les
ministres la vie du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques nous interroge sur
les moyens dont nous disposons pour
mettre en œuvre ce budget il juge
notamment optimiste les hypothèses sur
la croissance économique et la maîtresse
et la maîtrise de la dépense publique
j'y vois surtout une incitation à
engager plus vite les réformes
structurelles que nous portons la
réforme des retraites l'accompagnement
des locataires du RSA ou encore la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
pouvez-vous nous préciser comment ces
réformes ont un impact traduisent dans
les hypothèses émises dans ce texte
deuxièmement nous sommes tous soucieux
du poids de la dette que nous
transmettons aux générations futures
pour 2023 la dette coûtera
51,7 milliards d'euros nous sommes
engagés à maintenir le déficit sous la
barre de 5% du PIB pour l'année 2023
dans le budget que nous présentons le
poids de la dette en pourcentage du Pipe
baisse c'est une bonne chose c'est un
signe encourageant mais quel engagements
pouvons-nous donner messieurs les
ministres générations qui nous suivent
que nous parviendrons à réduire cette
dette et que nous atteindrons
effectivement cet objectif de 3% d'ici
troisième question l'année du miel 2 a
été marquée par une très forte
instabilité le contexte de crise a
nécessité des dépenses imprévues comme
le bouclier énergétique qui a protégé
les Français de la haute colossale des
prix l'énergie ses dépenses d'urgence et
le contexte actuel ont entraîné une
augmentation de près de 21 milliards
d'euros par rapport à la loi de finance
initiale de l'année dernière
nous restons cependant résolument engagé
à réduire le poids de la dépense
publique sur le quinquennat à 53,8% le
budget pour 2023 prévoit une baisse en
volume de dépenses de l'État et ses
opérateurs de 2,7% à cet égard
pouvez-vous préciser l'ampleur de la
maîtrise de la dépense que vous
présentez pour 2023 par sous secteurs
d'administration publique
quatrième question 2000 entre 2012 et
2017 les dotations générales de
fonctionnement collectivités territoire
territoriales ont drastiquement baissé
depuis 2017 notre majorité soutient les
collectivités territoriales il y a
augmenté leur niveau de dotation pendant
la crise sanitaire nous avons porté de
nombreuses mesures afin d'aider des
collectivités et dès cette année nous
avons soutenu nous avons soutenu dans le
cadre de du pdfr la Banque Postale vient
d'annoncer que la capacité
d'autofinancement des collectivités
territoriales devraient cette année
baisser simplement de 4% ce résultat est
encourageant il peut se pendre cacher de
très grandes disparités entre les
différentes collectivités territoriales
seriez-vous vers un dispositif d'aide
ciblée des collectivités territoriales
les plus impactés en 2023
cinquième question le bouclier tarifaire
est un dispositif massif et efficace
vous proposez qu'il soit reconduit en
2023 avec une augmentation contenue de
15% pour les ménages les plus modestes
une augmentation de la valeur du chèque
d'énergie est envisagée pouvez-vous nous
préciser dans quel texte financier il y
a quelle hauteur sera ce chèque enfin
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire vous
en avez vous l'avez évoqué je voudrais
juste m'en assurer vous pourriez vous
préciser le montant des reports de
crédit entre 2022 et 2023
parmi ces reports est-il possible que
figure ceux pour protéger les
entreprises au titre du dispositif dit
énergo intensif qui n'a comme vous
l'avez précisé pas réellement fonctionné
à ce stade quels sont les
perspectives de le voir en 2023 donc
prolongée au-delà des crédits votés en
2022 je vous remercie
Bruno Le Maire Gabriel pour les réponses
merci monsieur le président
d'abord sur le
merci une fois encore pour
la qualité des débats que nous avons
dans cette commission des finances je
pense que nous y sommes tous très
sensibles et que nos compatriotes qui
nous écoutent le sont également
sur les prévisions que nous faisons
personne ne la prétention d'avoir la
vérité révélée dans ses potes de grande
instituts et certainement pas moi
et je m'estime pas le risque demain la
situation en Ukraine se dégrade encore
que le contexte géopolitique se dégrade
encore et que l'impact sur les prix
d'énergie soit encore plus fort mais ça
n'est pas notre scénario central
notre scénario central c'est celui d'une
situation géopolitique qui reste stable
et où le stockage après de 100% de nos
réserves de gaz la diversification des
approvisionnements sur laquelle nous
avons travaillé depuis plusieurs mois
le début de la sobriété énergétique et
la réduction de la consommation
doivent nous amener à une situation
meilleure sur le front de l'énergie et
je constate d'ailleurs que quand on
regarde les prévisions de la Banque de
France le scénario central était un
scénario à 0,5 il y a un scénario à 0,8
qui est proche d'une autre et que
scénario très négatif c'est dans des
conditions géopolitiques extrêmement
dégradées qui ne sont pas totalement
improbables et qui ne sont pas notre
scénario central c'est pour ça que je
maintiens ce chiffre de croissance
positif pour
2023 même chose sur l'inflation j'ai dit
quelle durée quelques mois oui elle dure
quelques mois à niveau élevé et je
rappelle que dans les chiffres qui sont
donnés par la Banque de France le
référentiel c'est celui de l'inflation
des prix harmonisés européens si on
retraduit ça en IPC Insee c'est-à-dire
la référence qui est celle du PLF 2023
on tombe bien sur les 4,2% qui sont
retenu par le gouvernement donc là il y
a un décalage de référentiel
sur le quoi qu'il en coûte là j'assume
une divergence sur le fond nous ciblons
de plus en plus et dispositifs il y
avait une remise carburant qui
concernait tous nos compatriotes prend
fin à la fin de l'année 2022 donc c'est
vrai que les 30 centimes d'euros de
réduction à la pompe on voit tous sur
les stations services françaises ont
vocation à disparaître d'ici la fin de
l'année et nous nous réservons la
possibilité si jamais les prix du
pétrole de flambé à nouveau de cibler
les dispositifs uniquement sur les
personnes qui travaillent c'est le
dispositif qui est prêt et qui sera
uniquement sur les personnes qui
travaillent et uniquement en cas de
nouvelles flambées des prix à la pompe
même chose sur les prix du gaz c'est pré
d'électricité ils ont été gelés ils ont
été plafonnés à 4% cette fois-ci nous
faisons passer une hausse tout
simplement parce que nous devons
anticiper l'évolution si effectivement
l'inflation reflux progressivement en
2023 nous voulons éviter un effet de
second tour ou la France en gros serait
rattrapé par la patrouille parce qu'elle
n'aurait pas ajusté ces dispositifs donc
je pense qu'il est très important même
si c'est compliqué à expliquer d'ajuster
progressivement nos dispositifs en
revanche qu'il faille plus
d'investissement en matière de
transition écologique qu'il faille
réfléchir à des rénovations globales
pour ma prime rénov moi j'y suis tout à
fait prêt mais c'est justement réduisant
la volure sur les dispositifs de
protection pour les cibler sur ce comme
on le plus besoin que nous dégagerons
aussi des marges de manœuvre
s'agissant des baisses de recettes
là aussi je veux être très précis sur
les choix qui ont été les nôtres parce
que je pense vraiment que c'est des
choix qui sont responsables je rappelle
que nous avons pris comme première
décision en écoutant d'ailleurs les avis
du au conseil de faire en deux fois la
baisse de la CVL nous avions prévu de la
faire en une seule fois j'ai moi-même
proposé au présent de la République à la
première ministre de le faire en deux
fois pour tenir compte de la situation
de finance publique je pense que c'est
plus responsable je crois que cette
suppression de la c.ae sera
utile pour l'industrie elle bénéficiera
à 75% des PME
et donc je pense que ce sera un
soulagement pour tout le tissu productif
français en revanche nous avons accepté
de décaler toutes les mesures sur les
transmissions
pourquoi parce que dans cette période où
nous voulons relancer en priorité
l'activité économique et défendre notre
tissu industriel nous avons estimé que
l'engagement se transmission qui sera
tenue n'est pas la priorité absolue donc
nous avons décidé de décaler d'un an la
mise en place de ces mesures sur la
fiscalité du transmission côté promis
par le Président de la République enfin
soit une niche fiscale ça c'est un point
d'accord que je veux marquer avec vous
moi je suis prêt à reparler sur les
niches fiscales je considère qu'on peut
faire plus qu'on peut faire mieux ça
fait un peu près
de 6 ans maintenant que nous essayons et
je pense que ça vaut le coup de
continuer à tenter
car je considère que il y a des marges
de manœuvre sur les niches fiscales
là-dessus je vous rejoins si je ne
citerai pas le cire en premier car je
considère qu'il est important pour
l'innovation pour le reste je sais bien
que c'est la plus importante ça ne m'a
pas échappé mais pour le reste il y a
beaucoup de niches fiscales sur
lesquelles je considère que nous pouvons
faire des économies sans affecter notre
croissance ni pénaliser des entreprises
sur la question de la taxation je redis
que nous nous ne voulons pas ajouter des
impôts à des entreprises qui créent des
emplois qui redistribuent des salaires
qui paient des impôts à l'étranger je
crois que l'audition du dirigeant de
Total était utile de ce point de vue là
nous voulons simplement prélever des
rentes que nous trouvons indues pour
nous permettre de financer le bouclier
et l’ingétique enfin sur les retraites
vous soulevez dans le fond un débat
politique est un débat majeur c'est un
point d'accord que j'ai aussi avec vous
c'est un des points d'accord aussi que
j'ai avec Philippe Martinez cela ne
m'arrive pas souvent je considère que
l'enjeu du travail des personnes de plus
de 55 ans que je l'appellerai pas les
seniors je ne vois pas très bien ce
qu'elles ont de seniors les plus de 55
ans
qui ont de l'expérience qui ont des
qualifications qui ont
un savoir-faire à transmettre
doivent pouvoir travailler plus
longtemps et ce que nous observons c'est
que quand vous décalez l'âge légal de
départ et bien mécaniquement cela amène
des personnes de plus de 50 à continuer
à travailler et que leur savoir-faire
leur expérience est utile et quand je
compare avec les autres pays européens
quand je vois que le taux d'emploi des
seniors pour prendre ce terme et de plus
de 70% en Allemagne en d'autres pays
européens et qu'il est à 54% en France
un peu moins je me dis qu'il y a quelque
chose qui cloche et que nous nous
privons de compétentes savoir-faire qui
sont utiles pour le pays je pense que
c'est un débat de société qui mérite
d'être posé
il y a beaucoup de questions qui
s'adressaient aux ministres des comptes
publics juste indiqué qu'une réforme des
retraites telle que nous l'envisageons
pourrait avoir jusqu'à
0,2 points d'impact sur la croissance
française 0,2 points de richesse
supplémentaire qui se relient à la
réforme des retraites et un taux
d'activités qui augmenterait dans notre
pays sur la maîtrise des 3% de
déficits publics je redis que notre
stratégie repose à la fois sur la
croissance les réformes de structure et
la réduction des dépenses publiques
Gabriel vous répondra sur les
collectivités locales et sur le bouclier
tarifaire s'agissant du report de crédit
pour les entreprises nous reporterons
1,5 milliards d'euros de crédit sur 2023
pour financer et dépenses liées à la
protection des entreprises les plus
exposées à la concurrence et qui ont les
factures énergétiques les plus élevées
merci peut-être sur deux points d'abord
sur l'intervention du Président
je veux revenir d'abord sur la question
de la taxe d'habitation que vous avez
mentionné sur la dernière étape de ça
suppression moi je veux dire qu'il est
important que cette dernière étape est
lieu d'abord parce que je pense qu'on ne
peut pas vivre
durablement avec un impôt dans
l'essentiel de la population serait
exonérée ensuite parce que ce qu'il y a
derrière en terme que j'entends
régulièrement sur vous allez supprimer
la taxe d'habitation pour les 20% les
plus riches je ne suis pas certain que
ce soit le terme exact plutôt les on va
dire les 20% les moins modestes puisque
on parle d'ici de contribuables dont le
revenu fiscal de référence démarre à
29000 euros par an et quelques c'est ça
les 20%. ça démarre à ce niveau de
revenus fiscal de référence donc ça me
semble important qu'on aille au bout de
cette réforme ensuite sur la question
des retraites vous avez indiqué c'est
pas normal que les retraites contribuent
ce ne serait pas normal contribue pour
l'éducation pour la transition
écologique etc mais aujourd'hui c'est
l'inverse qui se passe aujourd'hui les
moyens que nous mettons pour
subventionner nos retraites qui sont
déficitaires c'est des moyens que nous
ne pouvons pas mettre en plus pour
l'éducation pour la transition
écologique etc et quand on parle de
moyens supplémentaires liés à la réforme
des retraites pour pouvoir accomplir un
certain nombre d'investissements on ne
parle pas uniquement du gain budgétaire
on parle et Bruno Le Maire l'a dit de
recettes supplémentaires liées à un taux
d'emploi qui s'améliore dans notre pays
avec plus de gens au travail donc plus
de cotisations donc plus de recettes
fiscales aussi puisqu'il y a plus de
consommation dès lors qu'il y a plus de
revenus je viens ensuite sur les
questions de
Jean-René Cazeneuve qui nous a interrogé
sur plusieurs points d'abord sur la
maîtrise des dépenses j'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure que les dépenses de l'État les
baisser de 2,6% en volume la dépense
globale en volume baisse de 1,5 % en
2023 y compris relance et urgence
les facteurs de modération c'est
s'agissant de l'État la baisse des
dépenses de relance et d'urgence c'est
8,8 milliards d'euros c'est la maîtrise
globale des dépenses que nous demandons
à chacun à chaque ministère même s'il y
a évidemment des augmentations de crédit
pour répondre aux priorités politiques
sur la sécurité sociale j'aurai
l'occasion d'être auditionné ce soir par
la commission des affaires sociales mais
évidemment la commission des finances et
aussi intéressée par le PLFSS c'est
l'allègement des dépenses liées au covid
on a un déficit de la Sécurité sociale
qui s'améliore très nettement en 2023
par rapport à 22 notamment parce que
déficit de la branche maladie s'améliore
grâce en grande partie à la sortie de la
phase aiguë de la crise du covid et sur
les collectivités locales c'est la
baisse de 0,5% en volume qui est prévu
dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques je viens ensuite sur
la question des reports de crédit qui a
été posée aussi par Jean René Cazeneuve
les reports le volume de report n'est
pas estimer finement à ce stade puisque
vous savez que cela se fera dans le
cadre de la prévision d'exécution puis
en janvier février l'objectif c'est de
limiter le volume des reports par
rapport aux dernières années on a eu
l'occasion notamment des battants du
projet de loi de règlement de revenir
sur ses reports très importants qui
avaient eu lieu dans la phase aiguë de
la crise covid et du quoi qu'il en coûte
ou certains budgets étaient estimés à
grosse maille de manière la plus
protectrice possible et donc il y a eu
beaucoup de reports on souhaite
évidemment les limiter pour les aides
aux entreprises energo intensifs
évidemment les crédits non utilisés pour
ce dispositif sur 22 pourront être
reporté sans aucune
difficulté et l'article 36 du PLF
prévoit d'ores et déjà une liste de
programmes qui peuvent dépasser la
limite de report de 3% qui est prévu à
l'article 15 de la LOLF voilà pour ce
point également sur les collectivités
locales
j'étais devant le CFL tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire globalement
fin 2021 la situation financière des
collectivités locales étaient plutôt
bonne plutôt très bonne même au niveau
global avec une capacité
d'autofinancement nettement supérieure à
celle d'avant Chris covid avec 15
milliards d'euros de trésorerie en plus
sur les comptes du Trésor donc notamment
parce que l'État a apporté un soutien
direct pendant la crise covid aux
collectivités de 10 milliards d'euros et
un soutien indirect massif aussi
que sur 2022 la photo est plus floue
puisque évidemment les dépenses
augmentent pour les collectivités sur
l'énergie sur l'alimentation les
dépenses de masse salariale liées au
point d'indice mais je veux rappeler que
les recettes augmentent aussi en 2022
pour les collectivités locales les
recettes les recettes d'imposition
foncière locale les recettes de TVA j'ai
eu l'occasion d'annoncer tout à l'heure
la révaluation des recettes de TVA qui
vont être transférées aux collectivités
locales au mois d'octobre on tablé et on
avait annoncé aux collectivités locales
donc pour les fractions de TVA c'est
régions départements EPCI on leur avait
annoncé qu'ils auraient des recettes en
augmentation de 2,89% sur l'année 2022
on a réévalué en raison des recettes de
TVA qui sont plus importantes ce sera
9,6%
trois fois plus que ce qui avait été
prévu plus trois fois plus même ça veut
dire que le 20 octobre
les régions les départements et les EPCI
vont recevoir 2 milliards 500 millions
d'euros de plus que ce qui avait été
annoncé de recettes de TVA c'est un
milliard pour les régions un milliard
pour les départements 500 millions pour
les ecpi EPCI la fiscalité locale
progresse aussi du fait de l'inflation
et de certaines collectivités qui ont
décidé de revaloriser leur taux voilà je
dis simplement cette réalité et quand
bien même il y a une dégradation genre
René Cazeneuve l'a rappelé de la
capacité d'autofinancement cette année
et qu'elle est dégradée par rapport à
2021 elle reste quand même supérieure à
celle de fin 2019 est-ce que ça veut
dire que tout va bien pour tout le monde
évidemment non ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on continue à agir c'est quoi agir
moi je le dis le premier levier d'action
pour soutenir les collectivités locales
dans leur budget c'est l'action qui est
menée au niveau européen notamment par
Bruno Le Maire pour arriver à refroidir
les prix du marché de l'énergie parce
que si on reste avec une telle explosion
des prix de l'énergie de toute façon ça
sera intenable pour les collectivités
pour les entreprises pour l'État donc on
doit réussir à refroidir ces prix et
c'est ce qui est mené actuellement et
Bruno Le Maire a fait des propositions
très concrètes sur ce sujet là ensuite
l'action qu'on peut mener c'est
d'accompagner les collectivités qui sont
les plus en difficulté c'est le sens du
bouclier et du filet de sécurité que
vous avez voté cet été 430 millions
d'euros à l'initiative de Christine
pires Boone le décret va sortir dans les
prochains jours
et les actes premiers acomptes seront
versés au mois de novembre pour les
collectivités je rappelle que pour les
collectivités et on estime que 25% des
communes pour en bénéficier c'est
jusqu'à 70% de la hausse de dépenses
d'énergie de dépenses d'alimentation et
jusqu'à 50% de la hausse de ma salariale
qui seront compensés par l'État mais ça
serait faux de dire et je serai en train
de vous mentir que de vous dire que
l'étape peut être le garant en toute
circonstances des hausses de dépenses
contraintes pour les collectivités
locales ça n'est pas vrai de le dire on
peut pas dire ça arrêtez c'est qu'on n'a
pas les marges de manœuvre qui nous
permettent de le faire et donc il faut
qu'on ait un accompagnement ciblé c'est
la même logique qu'on a pour nos
concitoyens pour accompagner ceux qui
sont plus les plus en difficulté
merci on va passer aux orateurs de
groupe
je serai assez drastique sur les deux
minutes parce que nos ministres doivent
partir à 17h15 au Sénat
et donc si on dépasse on n'aura pas le
temps ensuite d'avoir des autres
orateurs Mathieu Lefebvre pour groupe
Renaissance merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs les ministres pour cette
présentation d'un budget qui s'inscrit
dans un double contexte politique et
économique inédit politique tout d'abord
auquel vous avez répondu par une
démarche singulière et elle aussi
inédite que nous devons tous saluer je
pense au dialogue de Bercy et économique
ensuite puisque l'environnement
international nous impose de répondre à
des défis qui sont gigantesques comme la
crise énergétique nous le rappelle
chaque jour alors dans le fond face à
ces défis et si nous souhaitons
continuer à protéger les Français il
existe plusieurs familles de solutions
soit on augmente l'endettement soit on
augmente les impôts soit on baisse les
prestations soit on augmente la quantité
de travail dans ce pays et on faire en
sorte que le travail soit mieux rémunéré
tout en continuant à maîtriser nos
finances publiques c'est le choix qui
est fait dans ce budget et c'est l'une
des priorités qui est à donner à ce
budget de la même manière que ce budget
prévoit également des baisses d'impôts
massives vous l'avez dit messieurs les
ministres l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
plus de 6 milliards d'euros qui ne
seront pas prélevés sur les ménages pour
un Français qui gagne 2000 euros c'est
200 euros en moins l'an prochain
priorité également au réarmement
régalien de l'État je n'y reviendrai pas
priorité au financement des dépenses
d'avenir l'éducation nationale c'est
ainsi que nous allons pouvoir financer
2000 euros en début de carrière pour les
professeurs
cependant il faut bien se rendre compte
que notre situation de finance publique
elle est dans un contexte extrêmement
défavorable si elle nous arrivons à 3%
en 2027 nous serons le dernier grand
pays de la zone euro à y arriver nous
avons un endettement qui va franchir les
3000 milliards d'euros donc je l'ai dit
nous avons deux possibilités nous pour
pour parvenir à réduire cette situation
c'est un augmenter la quantité de
travail baisser les impôts et libérer
l'activité et maîtriser nos dépenses
publiques ma question elle porte sur le
budget vert messieurs les ministres je
voulais savoir comment il était possible
d'augmenter le volume de dépenses qui
sont analysées dans le rapport sur
l'impact environnemental du budget
général et deuxièmement est-ce qu'on
pouvait travailler à son extension aux
collectivités territoriales
Jean-Philippe Tanguy pour le
rassemblement national
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
coûtait à force d'être de décrire des
romans ou d'être vous-même un personnage
well beckin je me demande monsieur le
ministre si votre perception de la
réalité est des fantasmes n'est pas
gravement entamé je vous vivez dans un
monde qui semble contrôler et vous
donner à l'irrationalité de votre
politique un semblant de rationalité qui
ne trompe personne la réalité c'est que
quand on voit les hypothèses sur
lesquelles votre politique se forme et
les réponses auxquelles vous apporter
vous continuez d'être un capitaine d'un
navire dans une tempête qui n'a plus de
gouvernail qui n'a plus de voile qui ne
sait plus où il va et qui espère que
l'horizon se dégagera d'elle-même mais
l'horizon ne va pas se dégager monsieur
le ministre tout seul c'est aux hommes
politiques et c'est aux dirigeants de
prendre leur responsabilité de prendre
des décisions qui cassent la fatalité
qui permet de reprendre le contrôle de
ce qui se passe le budget que vous
présentez est un budget de soumission
c'est un budget de victimes de la
mondialisation de victimes de
l'inflation de victimes de la guerre et
en plus de victimes qui a allumé un
incendie qui ne sait plus
ne le sait plus éteindre vous ne vous
attaquez pas aux pilier qui font
l'inflation en particulier la fierté
énergétique ce que vous présentez comme
un bouclier tarifaire n'est qu'en fait
qu'une subvention par les contribuables
de la spéculation vous êtes en train de
faire payer par les impôts des Français
ou la dette des Français par le déficit
les marges ahurissantes infondées
injustes spéculative des énergéticiens
et vous présenter le fait que vous
récupérez un surprofit qui n'a pas lieu
d'être comme une action politique mais
vous ne faites rien vous ne faites que
récupérer un argent qui n'a jamais
appartenu à ceux aux vertus vous le
récupérez pareil sur les illusions les
injustices vous prétendez vous cherchez
de l'argent mais il y a de jamais eu
autant de bénéfices qui devraient taxer
à leur juste proportion il faut rétablir
cette justice fiscale les injustices
aussi c'est dans les tabous que vous
faisez vous ne faites toujours rien sur
le fioul comme s'il se passait pas un
drame social en France vous ne faites
rien sur le bois alors que c'est votre
gouvernement qui a incité les gens à
chauffer au bois il ne s'en sortent plus
enfin les grands tabous l'Union
européenne 26 là on y touche pas le
déficit de la dette on y touche pas et
l'immigration évidemment on y touche pas
c'est sûr qu'à partir du moment où vous
sortez 100 milliards de dépenses
publiques de l'action politique vous
subissez voilà donc maintenant il y a un
moment les Français ceux qui nous
auraient dû se demandent quand est-ce
que vous allez reprendre le contrôle de
la situation arrêter de faire payer au
contribuable toutes vos erreurs merci
David Giraud France insoumise
merci bon messieurs les ministres voilà
donc avec un budget qui nous informe
quand même de fait inquiétant la hausse
des prix est plus forte que vous ne
l'aviez prévu et la croissance est plus
faible que vous ne l'aviez prévu alors
on pourrait croire que ça vous
inciterait à la prudence mais non le
conseil aux finances publiques nous
confirme que vos chiffres sont fragiles
aussi fragiles que vos éléments de
langage d'ailleurs parce que le 8 juin
vous disiez je vous cite nous sommes au
pic de l'inflation ensuite vous avez
réalisé fin août qu'il n'y aurait je
cite encore pas d'amélioration avant
2023 votre collègue monsieur Véran a
même découvert que le pic s'était
transformé je cite en un plateau haut de
l'inflation et maintenant on en voit
plus le bout en bref vous êtes trompé
lourdement
monsieur le ministre il y a une question
qui importe c'est est-ce que la crise
est derrière nous ou est-ce qu'elle est
devant nous parce que cet été vous nous
avez fait croire qu'elle allait passer
vite la crise puisque la crise était
temporaire vous avez dit qu'il fallait
pas augmenter les salaires ni les minima
sociaux et qu'un chèque suffirait ou
qu'une prime suffirait puisque la crise
passe vite
inutile de taxer les super profits
puisque cet enrichissement qui était
indécent n'allait pas durer trop
longtemps
inutile aussi de bloquer les prix vous
nous avez dit mais si la crise est à
venir comment on fait comment on fait si
la crise est devant nous alors on doit
soulager les classes populaires et
moyennes qui se saigne à la pompe et au
supermarché en faisant contribuer
notamment les plus fortunés au budget de
la Nation en rétablissant l'impôt sur la
fortune et si vous le faites pas alors
dis-nous c'est dites nous c'est quoi les
effets du ruissellement dont on nous
parle le temps si la crise est devant
nous on a besoin au plus vite d'une taxe
sur les super profits ne serait-ce que
pour équilibrer les contes de la nation
puisque l'équilibre des contes de la
nation a l'air d'être importante pour
vous si la crise est devant nous est-ce
que vous allez enfin mettre entre
parenthèses au moins entre parenthèses
l'objectif absurde de réduction des
déficits publics que vous appelez
réforme structurelle que j'appelle
destruction de nos biens communs parce
que c'est ça qui permet de faire face à
ces crises économiques écologiques
sociales sanitaire et là l'État est en
train de s'essouffler face à l'inflation
et puis on a quand même des choses
importantes qui arrivent je vous
interpelle sur la situation des
bailleurs sociaux les charges vont
exploser et c'est une situation
dramatique quant à la réforme des
retraites dont vous avez parlé je sais
que c'est pas bien de revenir sur une
parole mais il faudrait savoir quelle
parole parce que le Président de la
République en 2017 nous expliquer qu'il
y avait pas besoin d'un logement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite et qu'il
vaut mieux abandonner sa parole
qu'abandonner les Français qui ont le
droit au respect et au repos merci David
Giraud Véronique louvagi oui merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur les
ministres pour cette présentation je
voudrais réagir en premier lieu sur les
hypothèses que vous retenez et sur la
réponse finalement monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire que vous avez apporté au
Président de la commission des finances
en disant que c'était le scénario
central mais vous êtes bien le seul à
retenir une hypothèse comme celle que
tous les instituts au Conseil des
finances publiques considèrent que vos
hypothèses sont peu probables et nos
obstances les hypothèses qui sont très
optimistes vous ne réussissez finalement
pas du tout à diminuer notre déficit
avec des hypothèses très optimistes peu
probable vous n'arrivez qu'un déficit de
5% qui encore à un déficit très élevé et
finalement avec une hausse des taux
comme celle que nous connaissons avec
l'obligation que le pays va avoir
d'emprunter 270 milliards d'euros pour
financer notre déficit pour financer le
remboursement de la dette nous allons
devoir emprunter probablement à deux et
demi pour cent pour refinancer de la
dette qui était un taux bien inférieur
le deuxième point sur la hausse des
dépenses courantes la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques où vous en faites un
totem sur le ministre Gabriel attel vous
nous dites vous n'avez pas de boule de
cristal vous avez une boussole mais
encore faut-il que la boussole soit dans
la bonne direction c'est le Ministre et
là en matière de hausse des dépenses
courantes vous êtes à une hausse de 62
milliards d'euros entre 2022 et 2023 je
cite Pierre Moscovici qui indique que le
redressement des comptes publics n'est
pas assuré vous avez finalement une
trajectoire qui suit la trajectoire des
dépenses publiques sur le quinquennat
précédent de plus 140 milliards d'euros
vous auriez pu sur un nouveau
quinquennat donner une nouvelle
impulsion avoir un nouveau cap donner
des nouvelles orientations mais rien de
tout cela rien de tout cela est
finalement vous nous dites que le quoi
qu'il en coûte est terminé mais non le
quoi qu'il en coûte je suis désolé il
est peut-être axé d'une autre manière
mais il continue voilà donc cette
présentation et ce stade est décevante
elle est même inquiétante j'aurais
simplement une seule question sur le
maintien du bouclier énergétique
monsieur le min parler de 16 milliards
d'euros avec une redistribution des
rondes des énergéticiens est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un montant sur cette
rente merci
Marina Ferreri pour le groupe démocrate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mesdames messieurs
moi je ne dirai ni soumission ni
victimisation je parlerai de
responsabilité de stabilité et de
protection c'est deux textes nous
amènent à continuer la politique qui a
été engagée depuis quelques années celle
de protection des Français
d'accélération de la transition
énergétique et de poursuites de l'action
en faveur de l'entreprise et du pleine
emploi nous soulignons d'ailleurs les
élus du groupe démocrate les
perspectives encourageantes pour la
croissance fin 2022 certains pourraient
juger que pour 2023 elle est faible mais
elle reste positive dans le contexte
actuel relève de la prouesse et j'y vois
le fruit de l'action politique qui a été
conduite ces dernières années
ces projets ce projet notamment du PLF
assure également le renforcement des
missions régaliennes de l'État je pense
que ce sont des choses qui vous sont
chères comme les budgets importants qui
sont allés à la justice à la santé à la
sécurité et à l'éducation et je crois
que cela mérite d'être souligné
au-delà des mesures simples de
protection Enfin simple façon de parler
de protection des Français que nous
avons votés dans le cadre du périphér et
du PLF 2023 que nous vous proposons
je crois qu'il y a un volet important de
lutte contre la grande pauvreté et
notamment je tiens et nous tenons à
souligner le lancement du chantier de la
solidarité à la source qui est un
chantier très attendu par les français
concernant les collectivités
territoriales le constat de l'engagement
fort de l'État et du maintien des
dotations est à noter il y a une
orientation importante sur l'évolution
des dépenses de fonctionnement en
limitant leur évolution un rythme
inférieur de 0,5 points par rapport à
l'intuition à l'inflation nationale
c'est un geste d'ouverture fort
vis-à-vis des collectivités qui
méritaient d'être soulignés nous
partageons la nécessité de supprimer la
CVAE en soutien de notre économie et sur
les fonds verts nous avons le fond vert
d'un milliard et demi nous avons en
revanche une interrogation qui est son
articulation avec les autres dispositifs
aujourd'hui en vigueur notamment la des
cils et puis également un souhait
peut-être de retrouver
sur certaines mesures une forme
d'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
ensuite sur l'évaluation de la politique
publique et des qualités et la qualité
d'utilisation des fonds publics vous
savez que c'est des ce sont des choses
qui sont chères au cœur des élus
démocrates l'article 21 de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
instaure un dispositif d'évaluation
comment envisagez-vous son articulation
avec le travail parlementaire merci j'ai
pas si c'est lise manier ou
François je vivais qui parle François
Joly
merci monsieur le Président
excuse-moi François c'est Christine
piresbound d'abord je m'étais j'étais
tellement pressé de t'écouter
c'est pas très sympa pour moi mais bon
merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs les ministres pour votre
présentation alors je vais je vais faire
vite et ce sera peut-être un peu en
point et vous m'en excuserez alors sur
les retraites j'ai envie de vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre que le débat n'a
pas été tranché moi j'ai voté manuel
Macron au deuxième tour comme des
millions de personnes je n'ai pas voté
pour une réforme des retraites et je
n'aurais pas
la bonté de vous rappeler le score de du
président de la République au 1er et au
premier tour et première question
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
délai raisonnable c'est quoi un délai
raisonnable et est-ce qu'un amendement
au PLFSS est un délai raisonnable et
puisque vous avez parlé d'une réforme
des retraites j'imagine que vous avez
chiffré ce qu'elle pourrait rapporter
est-ce que c'est plus ou moins 8
milliards d'euros c'est à dire la
suppression de la CVAE
deuxième question sur les entreprises
électro-intensives et exportatrices vous
avez évoqué un plafond d'aide qui
passerait à 100 millions d'euros
pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement
monsieur le ministre de publier la liste
des entreprises qui seront bénéficiaires
de ces aides troisième point bouclier
tarifaire les tarifs réglementés vont
s'arrêter au 30 juin 2023 quid du
fonctionnement du bouclier à partir du
1er juillet 2023 monsieur le ministre
a-t-elle vous avez évoqué l'article 7 de
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques sur l'évaluation d'une mesure
fiscale avant sa prolongation très bien
pouvez-vous nous fournir l'évaluation
précise en termes d'emploi
d'investissement de relocalisation de la
suppression des 10 milliards de CVAE
avant d'aller plus loin
dernier point collectivité territoriale
il y a nécessité de considérer les
collectivités territoriales comme
vraiment un acteur à part entière
protecteur des populations comme comme
veulent être l'état si on est en
désaccord total sur le financement du
budget de l'État et sur
l'affaiblissement du budget de l'État
que vous avez entrepris depuis 5 ans
avec la suppression de 50 milliards de
ressources nous pouvons en effet trouver
un terrain d'entente sur certains
dispositifs pour les collectivités et
j'ai lu ce matin et vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure au CFL que la fin de les
traitement pour être compensée par enfin
une péréquation
verticale sur la DSU et de la DSR je
suis à votre disposition pour travailler
cet amendement que j'avais suggéré
effectivement lors des dialogues de
Bercy
François Jolivet
[Musique]
coupe son micro merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais d'abord vous indiquer au nom du
groupe horizon la parenté toute notre
satisfaction de l'initiative qui a été
la vôtre d'organiser les dialogues de
Bercy j'observe que beaucoup
d'intervenants ils font référence et le
premier d'entre nous le président de
notre commission sur le fond le PF que
vous nous présentez et que nous n'avons
pas encore lu dans le détail
parvient à un exercice semble-t-il assez
difficile c'est-à-dire protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français face à
l'inflation et tout en essayant de
contenir la dette publique afin que les
générations futures ne soient pas
hypothéquées dans la gestion de leur
présence
trois questions tout d'abord beaucoup de
d'intervenants lors des dialogues de
Bercy ont pointé des difficultés
rencontrées par ma prime rénove tout le
monde souhaitant avoir des
réhabilitations plus complètes le groupe
horizon se récemment ce qui va devenir
du monogeste très utilisé changement de
pompe à chaleur qui est destiné en fait
souvent à remplacer les chaudières fuel
qui ne sont plus réparables
deuxième question la loi de finances met
en place un fond d'accélération à la
transition écologique dans les
territoires qui seraient dotés d'un
virgule 5 milliards d'euros qu'en est-il
de ces conditions d'utilisation
avez-vous déjà une vision sur ce sujet
et ces conditions d'accès troisième
question le nouveau dispositif
d'assurance récolte se met en place avec
la loi de finances 2023 et donc il est
prévu un doublement du plafond de la
taxe affectée au Front national de
gestion des risques en agriculture
pouvez-vous nous donner ces montants et
qui est-il prévu dans ces conditions
d'utilisation je vous remercie
merci et bah ça pour le groupe
écologiste
alors ma première remarque c'est que le
cadre budgétaire que vous nous proposez
ne nous paraît pas du tout adapté à la
situation que ce soit sur l'objectif de
déficit budgétaire à 5 % ou sur votre
volonté de baisser les impôts avec
notamment la première tranche de la CVAE
qui nous prie de 4 milliards d'euros de
recettes fiscale ou votre refus de taxer
les sur profits alors que nous avons
besoin de recettes fiscales pour faire
face aux besoins sociaux non couverts
notamment dans l'éducation ou dans
l'hôpital il y a trois jours j'étais à
l'hôpital Saint-Antoine où il y a encore
150 lits fermés faute d'infirmière nous
ne comprenons pas que vous vous priez de
recettes fiscales pour couvrir ses
besoins vous opposez à notre demande de
taxe sur les surpris en disant que vous
allez ponctionner les rendre des
énergéticiens mais à ce stade ce ne sont
que les énergies renouvelables qui
reverse à l'état donc quels sont les
dispositifs que vous envisagez pour que
les producteurs d'énergie fossiles
contribuent également
mon deuxième point ce sera sur
l'insuffisance des budgets sur la
transition écologique particulièrement
sur la rénovation thermique vous disiez
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait tenir ses
promesses en politique le 17 mars à
Aubervilliers le candidat Emmanuel
Macron annoncé 10 milliards d'euros par
an pour la transition écologique j'ai
envie de dire où sont ces 10 milliards
au contraire les crédits de l'écologie
en dehors du programme 145 stagne ils
augmentent face à le nom de 2,3
milliards d'euros mais les crédits
dédiés à l'écologie dans le plan de
relance baisse un regard de 2,1
milliards d'euros donc nous ne voyons
pas d'augmentation des
crédits affectés à l'écologie et c'est
particulièrement vrai pour ma prime
rénov qui n'est dotée que de 2,5
milliards d'euros soit une bien faible
augmentation de 500 millions d'euros
alors que les besoins chiffrés par I for
see ou par la Mission Sichel que vous
avez vous-même missionné indique des
besoins entre 8,8 et 10 milliards
d'euros par an vous indiquez notamment
le dispositif MPR sérénité dispositif de
rénovation globale sera renforcée mais
quel est le montant qui est prévu pour
ce dispositif dédié aux rénovation
globale puisque c'est sur ce dispositif
que nous vous proposerons de renforcer
les moyens et la prise en charge puisque
comme vous le savez ce qui pêche c'est
bien les rénovations globales Nicolas
sont su pour le groupe GDR merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres face aux crises majeur que
vous avez cité la guerre en Ukraine la
crise climatique la crise sociale la
crise démocratique
vous faites à mon sens une faute
politique en restant dans le cadre et
dans les pas des règles libérales
européennes avec la réforme de la
retraite le massacre sur l'assurance
chômage qui ont des conséquences
terribles sur les peuples et offre
malheureusement des possibilités de
prise de pouvoir de l'extrême droite
comme c'est le cas chez nos voisins ne
l'oublions pas or avec votre PLF 2023
malheureusement vous confirmez le
désarmement fiscal en favorisant l'impôt
indirect au détriment de l'impôt direct
beaucoup plus juste temps en favorisant
l'impôt proportionnelle en lieu et place
de l'impôt progressif en faisant
basculer la richesse nationale vers plus
de rémunération du capital au détriment
de la rémunération du travail et bien
sûr nous aurons ce débat dans
l'hémicycle mais au-delà même de ce
débat il y a de très gros manques qui
sont autant de questions et
d'indignation parce que nous ne prenons
pas en compte les crises qui nous
assaillent où est le grand plan de
transition écologique la fameuse
planification écologique qui devrait
être hors calcul de Maastricht et est-ce
une option ensuite où est la grande
réforme du marché de l'énergie et une
véritable maîtrise publique de l'énergie
par un grand service public pour faire
cesser des rentes insupportables 45
milliards d'euros déboursés pour le
bouclier tarifaire en fait ce sont les
profits de Total demain c'est tout
simplement ça or l'objectif ce n'est
casser la rente ce n'est pas seulement
de la compenser pour nos concitoyens et
des énergies renouvelables d'ailleurs
payent 19 milliards en direct la CSPE 9
milliards et la Compagnie nationale du
Rhône un milliard sur ses 45 milliards
la taxation sur les super profits dans
ce cadre là n'est pas seulement une
mesure de justice fiscale une nécessité
vous avez tort de ne pas répondre à une
situation exceptionnelle par des mesures
exceptionnelles enfin où est le réel
soutien aux collectivités territoriales
ce qui a été annoncé cet après-midi ici
est indigent on nous parle de 430
millions d'euros de crédit du PLF ça ne
règle rien pour 2023 et même pour 2022
car votre filet de sécurité est
inopérant vous nous parlez du TRV c'est
uniquement pour les toutes petites
communes c'est une faute politique que
d'abandonner ainsi nos collectivités
territoriales d'abord les communes qui
sont creusées de notre République et de
ses valeurs et qui vont être le dernier
recours de nos concitoyens merci Charles
de Courson pour le groupe
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres première question
malgré un cadrage macroéconomique trop
optimiste moins sur l'inflation que sur
la croissance du PIB et sur l'évolution
des taux d'intérêt le déficit effectif
est stable à 5 % niveau parmi les plus
élevés de nos partenaires européens le
poids de la dette publique est quasiment
stable en 2023 et ce jusqu'en 2027 et le
taux de prélèvement obligatoire à 44,7%
du PIB et niveau encore plus élevés
qu'en 2021 où l'été de 44,3 alors ma
question est très simple
pourquoi cette situation parce qu'il n'y
a pratiquement pas d'économie réelle la
hausse des dépenses publiques n'est pas
de - 1,5% en volume comme Monsieur le
Ministre Attal vient nous l'indiquer
mais d'après le conseil de plus 0,7%
puisque vous prenez l'indice des
prélacommation la consommation et pas
l'indice des prix implicite du pub et
donc et parce que vous avez baissé
massivement les recettes il y a d'après
le Haut Conseil 13-7 milliards de baisse
des recettes dont on n'a pas le premier
sous alors pourriez-vous nous indiquer
le montant des économies prévues par le
gouvernement dans ce projet de loi de
finance et deuxième question est-ce que
vous êtes ouvert comme vous l'avez
indiqué dans dialogue de Bercy a des
ventes amendements d'économie deuxième
question
au sujet des mesures concernant les
ménages en matière d'énergie du
persister avec des mesures générales et
uniformes mais tout à l'heure Monsieur
le Maire s'est déclaré ouvert à une
évolution on parle d'un bouclier
tarifaire à 16 milliards non compris les
8 ou 9 milliards via la CSP donc en fait
on est plutôt à 25-26 milliards alors
êtes-vous favorable à des amendements
qui permettraient de concentrer les
aides sur nos concitoyens qui ont qui en
ont le plus besoin
troisième question
concernant les collectivités
territoriales vous cassez le lien entre
entreprise et collectivités
territoriales en supprimant en deux ans
la 16 VAE mais si vous voulez le
maintenir il y aura une solution c'est
un dégrèvement et pas le dispositif que
nous proposons alors est-ce que vous
êtes ouvert à ce type il faut conclure
oh j'ai plus que deux questions
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire quel
est le coût du nouveau décret concernant
les entreprises l'impact sur les
entreprises électrolles et dernière
question très simple
où en êtes-vous de l'éventuelle
prélèvement exceptionnel sur les
bénéfices générés par les entreprises
notamment énergie merci
messieurs les ministres
merci monsieur le président
Mathieu Lefebvre sur le budget vert
est-ce que nous travaillons à son
extension la réponse est oui et tout ce
qui permettra d'étendre le budget vert
de le développer de lui donner plus
d'ampleur recevra un accueil favorable
je rappelle que nous l'avons déjà étendu
pour 2023 à France 2030 donc 30
milliards d'euros de crédit au transfert
à l'Union européenne et aux dotation de
soutien l'investissement local et qu'un
certain nombre de communes y compris des
très grandes communes comme Paris ce
sont déjà inscrites dans cette
perspective du budget vert donc la
réponse est oui et trois fois oui je
pense que c'est une dynamique qu'il faut
encourager et développer
Jean-Philippe Tanguy je note que vous
avez toujours un rapport compliqué à la
vérité
parler de soumission matin midi et soir
je dois dire qu'en matière de soumission
vous en connaissez un rayon soumission
Vladimir Poutine soumission à la Russie
soumission à la violence de l'armée
russe refus des sanctions contre la
Russie je le redis en matière de
soumission vous parlez en expert
partant de justice fiscale je rappelle
que le seul État qui s'oppose à la mise
en place d'un impôt minimum à 15% pour
éviter les visions fiscale optimisation
fiscale c'est la Hongrie de Monsieur
Orban que Madame Le Pen soutient matin
midi et soir quant au fioul vous avez
sans doute oublié que vous avez voté 230
millions d'euros de crédit de soutien en
ménage qui se chauffe au fioul je vous
le redis vous avez un rapport compliqué
à la vérité c'est dommage quand on est
membre de la commission des finances
David Guillard pour éléfi le plus
difficile est devant nous c'est ce que
j'ai dit au mois de juin
donc je crois pas avoir trompé les
Français sur la réalité de la situation
économique ni tromper sur la réponse que
nous avons apporté
je rappelle que nous sommes le seul pays
de la zone euro dans lequel le SMIC
c'est un minimum est indexé sur
l'inflation protection
qui indexé l'intégralité des prestations
sociales sur l'inflation protection
qui indexée l'intégralité des retraites
sur l'inflation protection qui a mis en
place un bouclier sur le gaz un bouclier
sur l'énergie protection
qui a mis en place une remise carburant
protection aussi de nos compatriotes
notamment les plus modestes et qui a
obtenu le total une remise
supplémentaire de 20 centimes d'euro et
quand vous discutez directement avec au
compatriotes et qu'ils vont à la pompe
et qu'il voit 50 centimes d'euros de
réduction sur le prix à la pompe je peux
vous dire qu'ils savent très bien ce
qu'ils j'obtiennent et qu'il préfère que
ça aille dans leur poche plutôt que dans
la poche du Trésor public
nous avons également obtenu des banques
un plafonnement à 2% des frais bancaires
ou par des plus modestes nous avons
obtenu que le niveau maximal de frais
bancaire mensuel passe de 3 euros à 1
euro nous avons obtenu un plafonnement
également de la part des assureurs nous
avons obtenu des remises de 750 euros
par container pour les transporteurs
maritimes donc oui nous nous sommes
battus depuis des mois pour que la
facture soit la moins lourde possible
pour les classes moyennes et pour les
ménages les plus modestes en France
enfin s'agissant des retraites vous
parlez de 2017 et pas exactement de vous
rappeler que nous sommes en 2022
pas en 2017 et que le Président de la
République a gagné l'élection
présidentielle il a été candidat il a
présenté son projet dans ce projet il y
avait une réforme des retraites qui
comportait une mesure d'âge 65 ans c'est
ce qui avait promis le président de la
République qui comportait aussi une
accélération du nombre de trimestres à
cotisés le président de la République a
gagné cette élection il est donc fondé à
mettre en oeuvre le projet pour lequel
il a été choisi par nos compatriotes
madame louvagi est-ce que nous sommes
les seuls à défendre cette prévision de
croissance non le Haut Conseil dit
lui-même que cette prévision de
croissance pour 2023 est ambitieuse mais
crédible et depuis à peu près 5 ans
qu'on me répète que toutes nos
provisions de croissance sont trop
ambitieuses je constate que la
croissance française se tient qu'elle
est solide moi je crois dans les forces
de la France et je crois dans les
capacités de l'économie française à
dégager des marges de croissance d'abord
parce que nous entreprises continuent à
investir que nous voulons les protéger
contre le risque énergétique et que nous
avons préservé la demande et que nous
avons également un taux d'épargne qui
reste élevé qui doit permettre de
soutenir la demande le cas échéant
enfin saisissant du gain que nous
faisons sur les énergies renouvelables
oui le bouclier énergétique c'est 16
milliards d'euros mais le gain sur les
oeulaires c'est 19 milliards d'euros
pour 2023 je le dis là aussi à tous ceux
qui disent vous ne taxez pas
suffisamment 19 milliards d'euros c'est
pas des clopinettes c'est beaucoup
d'argent pour financer notre modèle de
protection notre bouclier énergétique
qui résulte justement du prélèvement sur
les énergéticiens Marina Ferrer je crois
que les questions s'adressaient d'abord
à Gabriel Attal
Christine Pirès Bonn vous me dites que
vous n'aurez pas la cruauté de rappeler
le score d'Emmanuel Macron au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle moi je
vous le rappelais 28% et je vous
rappelle aussi celui d'un Hidalgo
1,7%. donc il me semble que quand on
compare l'un et l'autre l'un est plus
fondé que l'autre à défendre son projet
et à le mettre en oeuvre donc je
considère que quand on a fait 28%
les voir au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et qu'on a emporté le
second tour l'élection présidentielle on
est fondé en droit et en politique à
mettre en oeuvre le projet pour lequel
on a été élu quand aux entreprises
bénéficiaires de la CVAE c'est à 75 %
des PME à 25 % dans le secteur de
l'industrie c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus
que les 11% qu'on représente industrie
dans la richesse nationale donc ça me
paraît une bonne mesure puisqu'elle va
principalement aux entreprises
industrielles enfin sur l'évolution et
ce que a donné la suppression des 10
milliards d'euros d'un peu de production
moi la seule chose que je constate c'est
que le solde net d'emploi industriels
sur cinq ans pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans est positif je dis pas que
c'est un miracle c'est 17000 emplois si
on met dedans les destructions d'emplois
liées à la crise du covid mais nous
sommes dans la bonne direction et je
considère que lorsque pour la première
fois depuis des années et des années
nous mettons fin à l'hémorragie de
l’emploi industriel plus d'un million
d'emples industriels détruit enfin nous
recréons des emplois industriels il y a
plus de sites industriels qui ont été
ouverts l'année dernière que Lucien
industriels qui ont été fermés vous avez
des investissements majeurs qui ont été
faits comme celui de globalfandries à
Crolles à Grenoble avec Estée micro qui
nous permet d'être leader sur les semis
conducteurs mais quand on tient le bon
bout je pense qu'il ne faut pas le
lâcher et je suis prêt à ce que nous
rendions évidemment des comptes sur ces
choix là mais si jamais il y avait eu
des destructions d'un point industriels
par dizaines de milliers au cours des
années passées j'aurais bien été obligé
de constater que c'était pas la bonne
politique mais à partir du moment où le
sol est positif je considère que nous
sommes dans la bonne direction et par
ailleurs je pense que vous partagez
cette ambition la reconquête
industrielle c'est pas un sujet
uniquement économique
oui ça crée des emplois et des emplois
qualifiés bien rémunérés oui ça permet
de répondre aux attentes de beaucoup de
jeunes dans la population mais c'est
aussi un enjeu politique parce que
l'industrie est une part de la culture
économique française et l'hémorragie
industrielle se traduit aussi par des
désastres politiques donc reconquérir
l'emploi industriel pour moi est une
priorité vitale pas simplement du point
de vue économique mais aussi du point du
politique et par respect pour la culture
industrielle qui a toujours fait la
force de notre nation et croyez moi je
ne ménagerai pas mes efforts au-delà de
la baisse des impôts de production que
soit sur la formation sur la
qualification sur les CFA sur
l'installation des usines sur
l'accompagnement des usines face à la
transition énergétique et face à
l'augmentation des prix nous ferons tout
ce qui est nécessaire pour réussir cette
reconquête
François Jolivet vos questions
s'adressaient je crois à Gabriel Attal
et Vassas ont été recettes fiscales je
vous confirme que ces 19 milliards
d'euros alors pourquoi principalement
sur les énergies renouvelables tout
simplement parce que c'est une question
de justice nous avons pendant des années
garantie aux énergéticiens on va les
citer c'est total CNJ cedf un prix en
échange leur investissement soit dans le
soleil
soit dans les éoliennes voilà ça coûte
cher vous prenez un risque on vous
garantit le prix de rachat et pendant
des années et des années nous avons payé
des milliards d'euros ces énergéticiens
pour financer leur manque à gagner le
jour où le prix de l'électricité explose
et on est très au-dessus de ce prix
garanti c'est normal qu'il nous reverse
la différence c'est pour ça qu'on le
concentre sur les ENS je le redis c'est
près de 20 milliards d'euros de recettes
c'est considérable et c'est bien parce
que c'est efficace et que c'est juste
parce que il y a aucune raison ils ont
pas fait d'investissement en plus
l'année où ils ont touché ces milliards
d'euros de bénéfices ils ont simplement
bénéficié d'une rente mais cette rente
ou là récupérons et c'est toute la
différence est un vrai débat politique
qui est tout à fait noble et intéressant
entre ceux qui veulent taxer dans le
fond toutes les entreprises qui font des
bénéfices parce que c'est bien ça quand
on dit taxe sur les super profits la
réalité c'est une taxe sur les profits
tout court
et ceux qui veulent récupérer une rente
j'ai vu la proposition taxer toutes les
entreprises qui ont plus de 750 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et qui
font un stand de bénéfices ça s'appelle
une taxe universelle sur toutes les
entreprises nous ne voulons pas ça nous
voulons récupérer les rangs nous sommes
contre les rentes contre les bénéfices
indus contre des profits des entreprises
peuvent faire alors même qu'elles n'ont
pas investi qu'elles ne font que
bénéficier d'une explosion
conjoncturelle des prix de l'électricité
et nous le faisons à hauteur de près de
20 milliards d'euros enfin pourquoi
est-ce que nous taxons pas la production
d'énergie fossile va pour une raison
simple la France ne produit plus ni gaz
ni pétrole
donc il y a rien à taxé de raffinage il
y a un vrai sujet là dessus sur la base
de la proposition européenne je
reconnais bien volontiers c'est l'autre
volet la proposition européenne on a
l'occasion d'en parler mais la
production de pétrole de Total elle est
taxée dans les pays de résidence ça
s'appelle le principe de l'établissement
stable en matière fiscale et je pense
qu'il est bon de le respecter enfin sur
les rénovations globales je vous
confirme que nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à avoir ce débat il est compliqué
vous savez aussi bien que moi vous savez
que les coûts sont vertigineux et par
conséquent il y a une vraie question qui
peut se poser je trouve que c'est un
beau débat est-ce qu'il faut concentrer
les aides sur un nombre plus restreint
de personnes pour favoriser des
rénovations globales est-ce qu'il faut
maintenir un dispositif très large où il
y a moins de rénovation globale plus de
gestes individuels ce qui soutient aussi
des activités du bâtiment et l'emploi il
faut pas se le cacher parce qu'il faut
voir aussi il y a des choses dans leur
globalité moi je suis presque une
audience des bases je pense qu'il est
utile pour notre pays
Nicolas sangsue
vous parlez des armements fiscal je dois
dire que quand on a le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire qui reste le
deuxième le plus élevé de tous les pays
de l'OCDE je n'appelle pas ça
véritablement du désarmement fiscal et
je ne pense pas que nos contribuables
pensent exactement la même chose quand à
la part de rémunération du capital du
travail je rappelle que ça peut être
Dion des fierté française nous sommes le
pays développés qui a le mieux maintenu
la part de rémunération du travail par
rapport au capital et je pense que nous
avons tout intérêt à rester dans cette
direction là sur la réforme du marché
européen de l'énergie je vous confirme
notre détermination avec le président de
la République avec le Premier ministre
avec toute la majorité à porter ce débat
je rappelle que ça fait un an que nous
demandons la découplage du prix du gaz
et du prix de l'électricité ce couplage
entre près du gaz et prix d'électricité
est une aberration économique et une
aberration environnementale j'ai eu mon
homologue allemand Robert abbecq au
téléphone à plusieurs reprises sur ce
sujet et nous continuerons à nous battre
en ce sens cela me paraît absolument
indispensable enfin Charles de Courson
je veux juste vous dire que bien entendu
que les amendements de proposition
d'économie recevront un accueil
favorable de notre part
Gabriel un tout petit peu plus court je
suis désolé que ça tombe sur vous mais
pour qu'il y a d'autres questions elle
Bruno Le Maire a répondu à beaucoup de
choses donc je vais pouvoir être rapide
en complément sur le budget vert pour
Mathieu Lefebvre il sera il sera
présenté dans les prochains jours dire
aussi qu'on travaille avec Christophe
Béchu et Caroline cailleux avec les
associations d'élus à l'adoption d'un
référentiel national de budget vert ce
qui nous permettra de faire la vérité
entre guillemets sur les prix s'agissant
du budget vert pour l'État mais aussi
pour les collectivités locales à ce
stade il y a entre guillemets une
dizaine de collectivités pour lesquelles
Bercy a connaissance d'un budget vert il
y en a probablement beaucoup plus qui en
ont adopté un ici les Moulineaux chez
moi adopter un budget vert très tôt il y
a beaucoup de collectivités qui font je
pense que c'est bien si on arrive à
systématiser ça avec un cadre global
pour parler de la même chose donc on
travaille sur ce sujet là sur les
questions de Véronique louvagi moi je
veux revenir sur votre intervention
et indiquer que le rythme de réduction
de la dépense publique qui a été prévue
par le programme de stabilité et qui
s'inscrit très concrètement dans la loi
de programmation de la programmation de
finances publiques qui prévoit les
crédits sur plusieurs années c'est
l'effort le plus soutenu depuis 20 ans
deux fois plus que la réduction le
rythme de réduction dans le quinquennat
précédent deux fois plus j'entends que
vous critiquez entre guillemets la
marche pour l'année 2023 si on fait la
somme de tous les ministères c'est plus
22 milliards j'ai entendu un chiffre de
62 milliards c'est plus 22 milliards moi
j'entends les critiques mais à ce moment
là il faut nous dire ce qu'on retire ce
qu'on retire les 3 milliards en plus
pour la défense évidemment qu'il faut
continuer à armer notre défense est-ce
qu'on retire le milliard 4 en plus pour
nos forces de sécurité nos forces de
police est-ce qu'on retire le 3
milliards 7 pour l'éducation qui nous
permet de revaloriser les enseignants
est-ce qu'on retire le 6 milliard en
plus pour le travail qui nous permet
d'atteindre le million d'apprentis
est-ce qu'on retire les budgets pour
l'écologie qui nous permettent
d'accélérer la transition il y a un
moment il y a des choix à faire mais je
suis sûr que dans le cadre du débat
pourrait porter des propositions
d'économistes structurelle et qu'on
travaillera ensemble à cet objectif
Marina Ferrari nous a interrogé sur
l'article 21 de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques effectivement je
vais insister sur cet article qui fait
suite immédiatement au dialogue de Bercy
on a eu je crois que c'était à la
deuxième séance des dialogues de Bercy
un débat assez vigoureux sur la question
de la qualité de la dépense publique je
me souviens notamment l'intervention de
Monsieur Tanguy qui était intervenu sur
le sujet on avait cité notamment
l'exemple des dépenses de logement on
dépense beaucoup plus en France pour le
logement que chez nos voisins européens
pour une qualité dont chacun reconnaît
on n'est pas certain qu'elle soit au
rendez-vous et donc je me souviens très
bien qu'on avait eu un débat assez vif
assez vigoureux sur ce sujet et que
j'avais dit moi si vous voulez qu'on est
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui prévoit aussi
une partie gouvernance des finances
publiques un dispositif qui permet
d'évaluer la qualité de la dépense
publique j'y suis très ouvert et donc
très concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
on a mis en place une accroche dans la
LPF pour pouvoir avoir ce débat au
Parlement et pour pouvoir enrichir le
dispositif permet vous montrer à
Monsieur Tanguy que contrairement à ce
qu'il a pu dire c'est dialogues de Bercy
n'étaient pas uniquement de la com mais
que très concrètement on envoie le
résultat y compris dans la gouvernance
de nos finances publiques avec un
dispositif qui fait suite à un débat que
nous avions eu à l'occasion d'un de ces
ateliers donc très concrètement
qu'est-ce qu'on propose on propose un
cadre et dans les débats parlementaires
qu'on aura d'établir ensemble une liste
de politiques publiques dont nous
considérons qu'elle nécessite une
évaluation quant à la qualité de la
dépense publique c'est d'évaluer des
évaluations qui auront lieu ensuite
durant l'hiver et des rapports qui
seront remis concomitamment au dépôt de
la loi de règlement pour alimenter les
travaux du printemps de l'évaluation et
ce résultat de ces travaux pourra
ensuite alimenter le prochain PLF c'est
un exercice qui sera répété chaque année
donc on met en place un nouveau une
nouvelle brique dans notre gouvernance
des finances publiques sur Christine
Pirès bon et la CVAE Bruno Le Maire a
répondu peut-être un point juste sur
effectivement le dispositif qu'on a
annoncé pour abonder et dotations de
solidarité urbaine et dotation de
solidarité rurale évidemment très pour
qu'on y travaille ensemble je pense avec
le rapporteur général qui voulait aussi
proposer un mécanisme mais évidemment
pour cibler le mieux possible François
Jolivet sur le fond vert le fond vert il
visera notamment à soutenir la
performance environnementale des
collectivités donc je parle de
rénovation des bâtiments publics de
modernisation de l'éclairage public etc
l'adaptation des territoires au
changement climatique matière de risque
naturel de renaturation l'amélioration
du cadre de vie il portera également le
financement de la Stratégie nationale
pour la biodiversité à hauteur de 150
millions d'euros sur l'organisation de
ce fond vert ça relève vraiment des
prérogatives de Christophe Béchu et
Caroline cailleux nous on met l'argent
dedans mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il y a le la volonté d'en faire
quelque chose de simple et compris
accessible aux petites collectivités on
retient un peu ce qui s'est passé avec
tous ces appels à projets qui se sont
multipliés qui parfois ça fait un coup
d'entrée pour des petites collectivités
qui objectivement compliqué on veut
déconcentrer au maximum les fonds pour
que ça se fasse avec les préfets comme
interlocuteur tout ça est en train
d'être défini par mes collègues biches
et ca sur l'assurance récolte vous avez
posé la question aussi le montant des
crédits bruts budgétaires qu'on
introduit sur programme 149 de la
mission agriculture et de 256 millions
d'euros en PLF 23 vous avez posé la
question de la taxe affectée au
fondational de gestion des risques en
agriculture assis sur des cotisations
d'assurance dans le plafond est doublé
et donc elle passe donc de 60 millions à
120 millions en 2023 ajouter au crédit
européen du
Fonds européen agricole pour le
développement rural de 184,5 millions ça
fait qu'on atteint 560 millions d'euros
en tout de soutien public pour la
gestion des risques en 2023 pour à la
fois le subventionnement de l'assurance
récolte et les tâches de solidarité
nationale et je rappelle qu'il est prévu
que ce soutien public passe ensuite à
600 millions d'euros en 2025 donc on
voit que l'engagement du président de la
République pour soutenir nos
agriculteurs soumis à des aléas
climatiques majeurs et tenues sur ma
prime rénov ça répond aussi comme ça
directement à Madame SAS on est tous
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut
recalibrer le soutien pour qu'il aille
plus vers les rénovations globales on
avait un objectif au départ de 80000
passoires thermiques rénovées afin 2021
on est à 2500 qu'on voit bien que on y
est pas et donc ça nécessite d'avancer
dans le cadre des dialogues de Bercy on
a commencé en parler on va continuer à
travailler ensemble pour mieux calibrer
les aides madame ça ça posait la
question sur le niveau de soutien de
l'État pour le climat et la rénovation
énergétique moi je veux rappeler ce cas
l'analyse qui a été transmise par
l'Institut de l'économie pour le climat
qui est un signe donc indépendant qui
est régulièrement cité notamment par les
vers qui a dit que si on additionne les
financements climat dépenses budgétaires
fiscales opérateurs publics et acteur
privé on est à presque 15 milliards
d'euros et que donc la France est dans
un étiage de dépenses acceptable
soutenable mais qu'il faut mieux centrer
un certain nombre d'aides dont ma prime
rénove sur Nicolas sangsue qui a
qualifié notre soutien en collectivité
locale d'indigeants je ne reprendrai pas
ce terme vous l'imaginez je crois pas
qu'on parler d'un soutien indigent quand
comme je le rappelais à l'instant on a 2
milliards 5 de recettes de TVA en plus
qui vont arriver d'ici à la fin de
l'année quand on met en place un filet
de sécurité de 430 millions d'euros sur
2022 et que sur 2023 on est ouvert à
rééditer un système de filet si c'est
nécessaire que par ailleurs je ne l'ai
pas dit dans mon intervention linéaire
les concours financiers de l'État aux
collectivités locales en 2023 vont
augmenter d'un milliard 100 millions
d'euros le FCTVA augmente la prélèvement
sur essai de compensation à la
suppression des impôts de production
augmente un certain nombre de concours
augmente on rajoute à ça le fond vert on
rajoute à ça l'abondement des dotations
proposées par Madame pires bonne qu'on
retient de 210 millions ça me semble pas
être indigent du tout surtout dans le
contexte de finance publique qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui sur monsieur de
Courson on est évidemment ouvert des
amendements et des propositions
d'économie
sur la dernière question le dernier
réponse vous demandiez pourquoi est-ce
qu'on remplace pas la suppression de la
CVE par un dégrèvement tout simplement
parce qu'on ne veut pas continuer à
faire vivre un impôt fantôme ce qui veut
dire quoi ce qui veut dire des agents
publics mobilisés pour le calcul de
l'impôt ce qui veut dire des obligations
déclaratives assez lourdes pour les
entreprises et supprimer la c.e c'est
supprimer de la pression fiscale pour
les entreprises c'est aussi supprimer
des modalités des charges
administratives et déclaratives assez
lourdes pour leur simplifier la vie
c'est pour ça qu'on part sur une
suppression de la CVE
merci on va passer aux autres juste une
petite remarque je reviens pas sur le
fond mais sur la question des pour la
qualité du débat et des arguments
échangés sur les questions des super
profits ou alors taxe pour les bénéfices
ce qui est proposé c'est notamment le
référence divisé partagé c'est un seuil
de 25% supérieur à la moyenne 2017 2019
en termes de bénéfices qui à peu près ce
que propose la Commission européenne si
je me suis pas trompé pour les
énergéticiens Dominique Da Silva pour
Renaissance
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur deux points importants
qui concourent à l'objectif du plein
emploi un merveilleux cap fixé par le
président de la République et que vous
portez très clairement au nom du
gouvernement dans ce dans ce PLF et que
nous soutenons évidemment nous la
majorité présidentielle le premier point
est celui du financement pérenne de
l'apprentissage avec l'ambition
d'atteindre et dépasser le million de de
contrats d'alternance comment
appréhendez-vous le bon financement du
coût contrat avec les régions et avec
France compétences qui après ce
doublement du nombre d'apports
d'apprentis et qu'on ne peut que
féliciter accuse un déficit de près de 6
milliards d'euros le deuxième point
porte sur le grand besoin de logement
locatif pour les salariés les plus
modestes et le besoin de mobilité dans
le parc social quels sont les
orientations budgétaires ou les pistes
qui permettent d'y répondre je vous
remercie
Louis Marguerite Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président et messieurs
les ministres nous vous remercions pour
votre intervention comme ça a été évoqué
par par mes collègues de la majorité ce
budget cette loi sont de programmation
des finances publiques sont résolument
tournés vers l'avenir et à lire
protection du pouvoir d'achat et des
Français réhabilitation de la valeur
travail et je crois que ça traduit assez
clairement l'engagement de l'État et de
la majorité en matière de création de
poste par exemple dans l'armée où il y a
création de 1547 et TP dans la
gendarmerie avec la promesse tenue de la
création des 200 brigades de gendarmerie
dans nos circonscriptions et d'un autre
territoire et dans la justice avec une
augmentation inédite de 106 ETP et c'est
essentiel pour renforcer la présence de
l'État dans nos territoires et par
ailleurs comme je considère que la
réduction en tout cas le maintien la
trajectoire des démences publiques n'est
pas et tout sauf un objectif absurde
est-ce que vous pourriez nous indiquer
où se situe les efforts de l'État et
plus généralement de la puissance
publique en matière de réduction des
effectifs en tout cas en matière de
moindre augmentation des effectifs dans
la fonction publique je vous remercie
merci David Amiel
merci monsieur le Président donc le
bouclier tarifaire qui est un dispositif
unique en Europe vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le ministre permet d'éviter des
hausses qui seraient sinon huit fois
supérieur j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
dire que comme d'autres mesures il peut
être financé parce que la stratégie
économique du gouvernement est solide et
qu'il suffit d'ailleurs de voir ce qui
se passe au Royaume-Uni pour se rappeler
que quand on ne maîtrise pas son déficit
public l'impact de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et de l'inflation sur le
pouvoir d'achat et délétère mais
question porte sur le déploiement du
bouclier tarifaire en 2023 avec bien sûr
de fortes incertitudes sur les
évolutions du prix du gros mais aussi en
juillet prochain la fin prévue des
tarifs réglementés de vente du gaz et je
me demandais messieurs les ministres si
vous pouviez nous indiquer l'impact
éventuel que cela aurait sur le bouclier
tarifaire et sur son coup pour le budget
je vous remercie merci Charles
systemstool
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Finances et
concernent nos discussions européennes
puisque les notes quinquennat va
coïncider avec une remise à plat des
règles budgétaires européennes qui est
un chantier très important qui a été
demandé par la France depuis plusieurs
années qui a été confirmé par la
président de la Commission européenne il
y a 10 jours à Strasbourg lors de son
discours sur l'état de l'Union donc
j'aurai souhaité que que vous nous
donniez peut-être un peu plus
d'informations sur l'état de vos
discussions avec vos homologues au sein
de l'euro et de l'écofines sur ce sujet
et quels sont les les impacts que
pourrait avoir l'évolution des règles
sur nos travaux à nous à la commission
des finances et à l'Assemblée nationale
pour le quinquennat actuel merci
beaucoup
Michel Castellani
[Musique]
d'inflation en matière de croissance
plutôt vous envisagez 1% bon ce que le
au Conseil des finances publiques
considèrent comme un peu ambitieux ou du
moins peu réalisable est-ce que vous
avez imaginé qu'on soit pas au
rendez-vous de cette croissance là parce
que moi il y a un sujet qui m'interpelle
c'est le nombre d'entreprises que je
vois aujourd'hui pratiquer des arrêts de
travail sur les chaînes de production
deux jours voire trois jours par semaine
du fait du prix de la hausse du prix de
l'énergie si on duplique ce
phénomène-là sur 2023 je pense qu'on la
croissance va forcément être impactée
par ce mesure cette mesure-là deuxième
question sur les taux d'intérêt moi
j'aimerais voir des simulations avec des
progressions au-delà de 2 et demi
aujourd'hui on a deux cinq de taux
d'intérêt avec la banque centrale est-ce
qu'on est garanti je pense pas qu'on
puisse avoir de garantie sur une
stabilisation de le tout et comment on
peut estimer la dérive éventuelle merci
elle a Dupont Renaissance
merci
ce que nous sommes sortis du quoiqu'il
en coûte et que la majorité est
favorable aux mesures ciblées notre
modèle social qui vise à soutenir et
accompagner les plus fragiles je crois
que nous y sommes tous extrêmement
attachés je note dans les crédits que
vous nous présentez plus de 2 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour la mission
solidarité en crédit de paiement et un
peu moins en autorisation d'engagement
en matière de cohésion des territoires
c'est une hausse aussi de l'ordre de 700
millions d'euros mais je m'étonne du
recul de 30 millions en autorisation
d'engagement aussi j'aurai une question
Quels sont les priorités qui guident
l'action du gouvernement matière de
lutte contre la pauvreté et
particulièrement matière d'hébergement
d'urgence je vous remercie merci Franck
alizio rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord pour rappel nous
avons fait un rappel aux règlements via
mon collègue Jean-Philippe Tanguy
s'il y a une chose qui se porte bien
dans ces derniers mois ce sont les
recettes fiscales sur les ménages plus 6
milliards de TVA par rapport à 2002 plus
4 milliards et demi sur l'impôt sur le
revenu
oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre deux points sur les
collectivités locales la première chose
sur la baisse de la CVAE donc on nous
dit ça va être compenser intégralement
par la TVA et on prend une moyenne qui
est celle de 2020-2021 2022 or il y a
une baisse de la CVAE sur 2021 2022 sans
doute du fait d'un décalage de l'impact
de la crise sanitaire non œuvre ne
devrait-on pas dans le 2e temps inclure
le résultat 2023 s'il serait peut-être
plus juste ensuite on nous dit qu'on va
garder un lien avec les territoires avec
avec la dynamique de TVA qui serait
répartie j'espère qu'elle sera répartie
sur les EPCI qui s'implique vraiment
pour le développement économique et non
pas que ce soit on retrouve avec une
énième dotation de compensation ça c'est
le premier point sur la C VAE deuxième
point sur le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
articles 23 on refixe une norme
collectivité territoriale d'augmentation
de leurs dépenses alors qu'on est une
perspective c'est bien qu'on est une
norme avec une punition si elle ne
respecte pas ça paraît quand même très
délicat au regard d'autonomie financière
des collectivités et ça paraissait
irréaliste de donner le même cadre à
toutes les communes toutes les EPCI
toutes les régions de France et de
Navarre voilà Fabrice brun
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres notre pays Colin déficit
records avec une dette publique vous
avez creusé je rappelle à mon tour que
c'est 5 dernières années c'est 140
milliards d'euros de dépenses ordinaires
supplémentaires et vous poursuivez votre
fuite en avant d'où ma première question
d'être excessive en mode d'inflation et
des tôles internes qu'est-ce qui
concrètement dans le budget que vous
nous présentez aujourd'hui et de nature
à enrayer cette spirale infernale
négative ma deuxième question concerne
les niches fiscale susceptible d'être
supprimé comme vous l'avez effleuré lors
de votre propos liminaire Monsieur le
Maire quelles sont-elles qu'elles sont
celles que vous entendez cibler si vous
l'avez évoqué devant nous aujourd'hui ce
que vous devez avoir une petite idée et
pour la clarté de nos débats nous
aimerions la connaître
merci Karim benchek pour le groupe
écologiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en tant que rapporteur spécial
la mission action extérieure de l'État
je constate une légère augmentation des
moyens budgétaires et des ETP du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères permettez-moi deux questions
monsieur ministre pouvez-vous confirmer
devant la représentation nationale que
cette légère augmentation s'inscrit dans
une vision pluriannuelle de réarmement
de la diplomatie française à titre
personnel et au vu des premiers éléments
disponibles le budget présenté dès lors
qu'il ne s'inscrit pas dans une
perspective d'augmentation plus réelle
et loin de répondre à l'urgence du
réarmement de notre diplomatie face au
défi de notre temps donc qu'en est-il
monsieur le ministre ensuite
je souhaite vous demander monsieur le
ministre quel serait les dispositions
que le gouvernement serait prêt à
prendre pour nos compatriotes établis
hors de France qui subissent comme vous
le savez une augmentation du coût de la
vie depuis plusieurs mois en effet
aucune disposition ne leur avait été
adressée dans le PLFR cet été
pouvez-vous ainsi affirmer devant notre
commission qu'une augmentation pérenne
des moyens de l'État à destination de
nos compatriotes de l'étranger et bel et
bien prévu et si c'est le cas
s'intègre-t-elle dans une vision plus
réelle vous remercie
oui monsieur le ministre de questions la
première vous prenez le dialogue entre
le Parlement et le gouvernement et
il y a de nouvelles méthodes notamment
les dialogues de Bercy la question que
je vous pose c'était de savoir suite à
ce à ce dialogue qu'est-ce qui vous a
est-ce que des ça a amené à certaines
modifications du PLF ça c'est la
question que je n'ai pas sentie dans les
dans les réponses de voir si ce dialogue
a eu des conséquences la deuxième
question elle est plus liée au niveau
européen lors de la crise du covid de la
BCE a mis 2300 Milliards de financement
auprès
auprès des banques pour relancer
l'activité économique des prêts des
financements qui allaient jusqu'à moins
1% de pour ces pour ses financements la
conjoncture a changé la BCE a augmenté
ses taux on est passé à 0,75 pour lutter
contre l'inflation
les conséquences du dispositif font que
les banques engrangent par ce dispositif
là des super profits qui ont été
calculés quasiment de 24 milliards à 31
milliards sur l'ensemble de la zone bien
sûr de la zone euro les banques bien sûr
non les remboursent pas rapidement il y
a que 200000 milliards qui ont
remboursés ma question c'est que le
gouvernement va-t-il intervenir auprès
de l'Europe pour faire cesser
immédiatement ce dispositif la situation
est indécent que les banques font des
super profits indus merci Jean-Philippe
Tanguy vous aviez demandé un rappel au
règlement je vais vous le donner ça me
permet d'indiquer que en théorie la
séance qu'on peut les faire pas en
commission je vous avais dit oui donc je
vous passe et si on arrive à faire en
sorte que dans nos échanges on reste
aussi éventuellement en désaccord sur le
fond que courtois sur la forme ça nous
permettra d'éviter les rappels au
règlement je tiens assez à ça dans cette
commission merci
merci monsieur le Président je n'ai pas
d'autre choix que de faire un rappel au
règlement puisque monsieur le ministre
le maire a non seulement gravement mis
en cause les élus du rassemblement
national mais même c'est nous a injuriés
en osant dire que nous étions soumis à
la violence de l'armée russe Monsieur le
Maire vous avez le droit d'être ivre des
propres mensonges et de la propagande
d'État vous n'avez pas le droit
d'oublier qu'en tant que ministre de la
République vous devez respecter les élus
qui sait ici de quelques parties qu'ils
soient et à partir du moment vous n'avez
évidemment évidemment aucune preuve du
début des insultes que vous préférez à
notre égard les tiques républicaine vous
impose de vous taire et de ne pas
proférer ce genre d'accusation qui sont
un véritable poison pour la démocratie
et nous avons fait une résolution nous
allons déposer une résolution pour enfin
ces mensonges d'État cessent en faisant
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
qui montrera si oui ou non il y a des
ingérences étrangères et nous n'avons
aucun problème pour ouvrir nos coeurs et
notre réalité on verra si vous vous
ouvrez votre réalité et vos cœurs
différence qui peut être un flux de
manière bien réelle vos décisions merci
je parlais de de forme je crois qu'on
est en plein dedans la réponse au
ministre merci
bien je regrets de décevoir monsieur
Tanguy de ne pas me taire et de prendre
la parole je voudrais d'abord que sur la
question la taxation qui est un sujet
qui est parfaitement légitime nous
pouvons bien le débat et la réalité des
choses
la proposition de la nupes évidemment
acceptable comme toute proposition
issue des rangs de cette assemblée c'est
si j'ai bien compris la proposition
taxer toute entreprise dont le résultat
fiscal de 2023 serait supérieur de 25% à
la moyenne des résultats 2017 2019 et à
mes yeux taxer à entrepreneur dans le
résultat a progressé d'un quart par
rapport à 2017 c'est pas taxer des super
profits c'est taxé tous les profits de
toute entreprise qui réussit c'est un
premier point de désaccord
la deuxième chose c'est que vous parlez
d'une taxation jusqu'en 2025 donc ça
n'est pas une taxation exceptionnelle
c'est une taxation permanente et bon
courage à ceux qui voudront supprimer en
2025 ce type de taxation donc c'est tout
ce que j'ai voulu dénoncer c'est que
derrière ces mots qui sonnent bien
taxation des super profits il y a une
réalité taxation permanente de tous les
profits de toutes les entreprises je
rappelle par ailleurs que la proposition
de l'UE est très différente puisqu'il
s'agit d'un résultat 2022 supérieur de
20% par rapport à 2019-2021 donc une
période de temps qui est bien plus
rapprochée de la période de la crise
inflationniste pour un seul secteur
l'énergie et pour une seule année 2022
donc il y a une différence qui est
importante après chacun est jugent
chacun est libre de faire ses
propositions mais je vous dis simplement
bien reposer le débat
Dominique Da Silva sur les contrats
d'apprentissage et déficit de France
compétences oui il y a 6 milliards
d'euros donc il me paraît légitime ça va
faire partie des propositions qui
figueront dans le budget que nous
refroidissions la machine pour que
l'argent aille réellement aux apprentis
qui en ont le plus besoin Olivier du
socle s'exprimera sur le sujet sur la
réduction des effectifs question du
Marguerite
Gabriel Attal vous répondra David Amiel
sur le bouquet tarifaire je veux
rassurer effectivement nos compatriotes
qui s'inquiètent de la fin des TRV dans
quelques mois la creux continuera de
calculer un indice de prix de référence
par rapport auquel nous calculerons le
bouclier que nous avons mis en place
avec les 15% d'augmentation pour que il
n'y ait pas de risque de tomber des Prix
Charles Dixon school sur les règles
budgétaires européens j'ai fait un
certain nombre de propositions à nos
partenaires nous formaliserons dans les
semaines qui viennent d'abord est-ce
qu'il faut des règles oui on peut pas y
avoir de union monétaire s'il n'y a pas
de règle commune et plus
les situations politiques évoluent dans
la zone euro plus ne paraît nécessaire
qu'il y ait des règles communes ces
règles communes ont proposé qu'elles
reposent sur trois principes d'abord la
différenciation
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
il y a des écarts de niveau de dette de
quasiment 100 points entre les États
membres de la même zone monétaire il
serait absurde de ne pas différencier
les situations et les trajectoires j'ai
pas demandé un état qui a 158% de dettes
publiques de revenir à 60 ou même rythme
pour que celui qui est à 70 si un
principe de réalité qui s'impose c'est
pour ça que vous a proposé une
différenciation entre les États membres
de la zone la deuxième chose c'est
inappropriation c'est à dire que ce
serait aux États membres même de faire
les propositions de réformes
structurelles et de réduction de
dépenses qui garantissent le retour sous
les 3% de déficit quand nous proposons
par exemple la réforme des retraites la
réforme de l'assurance chômage nous
garantissons la crédibilité notre
trajectoire de réduction de la dépense
publique enfin un principe de
responsabilisation c'est à dire que nous
sommes tous comptables devant les autres
membres de la zone euro puisque cette
zone euro nous protège
donc nous devons respecter des règles et
si nous les respectons pas accepter des
conséquences qui peuvent en venir la
zone euro nous a protégé pour la crise
du covid elle nous a permis d'émettre de
la dette en commun il nous a permis de
protéger nos entreprises il est normal
qu'il y ait aussi un principe de
responsabiliser Michel Castellani sur la
Corse Gabriel Attal nous apportera les
réponses nécessaires il connaît bien le
territoire il l'aime autant que moi
Marie-Christine Dalleau vous avez
soulevé
un sujet absolument majeur qui justifie
aussi la politique que nous avons décidé
oui il y a des entreprises qui
ralentissent leur production parce que
les factures énergétiques explosent et
que cela revient moins cher de mettre
sous concours leur usine ou de ralentir
de 20 à 30% leur production que de
continuer à produire donc pourquoi
est-ce que je me bat autant un pour
faire baisser les prix de l'électricité
2 pour apporter des aides suffisantes
notamment aux énergos intensifs c'est
parce qu'au bout du compte ça coûtera
moins cher que d'avoir une crise
économique en plus de la crise
énergétique et toute notre ambition avec
le président de la République et la
première ministre a été d'éviter que une
crise économique s'ajoute à la crise
énergétique donc soutenir des
entreprises les aider sur le paiement
des factures découper le prix du gaz de
prix de l'électricité c'est faire en
sorte que les usines chez vous et
partout en France tournent à leur rythme
normal si nous leur apportons pas une
protection une baisse des prix et un
aide sur le règlement de leurs factures
nous aurons une baisse de production
nous aurons des délocalisations et nous
aurons une crise économique en plus la
crise énergétique c'est aussi pour cela
je profite de votre question qui est
essentielle pour dire que j'attends des
énergéticiens qu'ils aient un
comportement exemplaire vis-à-vis de
leurs clients et nous les réunirons dans
les prochains jours avec Agnès panier
renacher parce que je vois trop
d'entreprises qui me font remonter des
propositions de tarifs qui restent tout
simplement délirantes et quand je reçois
des élasticiens qui me disent dans mon
bureau nous on anticipe un prix de
l'énergie à 250 euros le mégawatts et
qu'ensuite font des propositions de
contrat à 400 ou 500 euros le mégawatts
à leurs clients il y a un problème donc
je souhaite que les énergéticiens soient
exemplaires je souhaite qu'il soit
solidaire de leurs clients je souhaite
que tout le tissu productif français
soit solidaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous les réunirons avec Agnès
panure une hachée dans les prochains
jours c'est là Dupont je crois que la
question s'adressait à Gabriel Attal
Franck alizio moi il me semble pas qu'on
puisse dire que le gouvernement est un
profiteur d'inflation quand il va mettre
50 milliards d'euros sur la table pour
protéger nos compatriotes et nos
entreprises nous sommes pas profiteurs
d'inflation nous sommes protecteurs
contre l'inflation et je pense que c'est
la politique que nos compatriotes
attendent de nous
je fais collectivités locales je
laisserai aussi
Gabriel répondre Fabrice brun sur une
niche fiscale n'a pas d'a priori sur le
sujet je rappelle que votre collègue
juste en face de vous a fait un certain
nombre de propositions je pense que si
nous y mettons tous ensemble vous
arrivons peut-être enfin à
réduire un certain nombre de niche
fiscales de je considère effectivement
que aujourd'hui elles sont inappropriées
je sais qu'il est d'usage de dire que
d'ailleurs chaque niche fiscale il y a
un chien qui aboie très bien cela doit
pas empêcher la caravane du
rétablissement des finances publiques de
passer
Karim benchek je ne m'exprime pas sur le
mystère de phase étrangère je suis un
ancien de ce ministère donc je serai
conflicté Gabriel vous répondra à ma
place et enfin sur les dialogues de
Bercy Michel salade Gabriel vous
répondra aussi à ma place je veux dire à
quel point en tout cas cette initiative
qui revient entièrement à mon excellent
collègue ministre des comptes publics
était une bonne initiative et à mon sens
utile pour notre pays allez ça tombe
bien Gabriel Attal pour conclure merci
beaucoup
Louis Marguerite sur la question du
schéma d'emploi et effectivement un
certain nombre de créations prévus l'an
prochain elle corresponde elle
corresponde au programme présidentiel et
au engagement pris par le Président de
la République président s'est engagé à
poursuivre le réarmement dans le secteur
de la sécurité avec un doublement de la
présence des forces de sécurité sur la
voie publique à horizon 2030 ça veut
dire qu'il faut créer des postes
supplémentaires on en créera 8500 sur le
quinquennat dont 3000 dès l'année
prochaine le doublement passera aussi
par une réforme des vacations des rides
par le transfert d'un certain nombre de
missions aujourd'hui effectuées par des
agents de sécurité intérieure par
exemple pour le transfert de malade ou
la garde de bâtiments publics mais c'est
ça qui explique les hausses le mandat
que nous avons de la première ministre
c'est la stabilité de l'emploi public
sur le quinquennat ça veut dire que les
ministères pour lesquels l'emploi public
va beaucoup augmenter sont limitées il
se limite à ceux que j'évoquais à
l'instant les engagements de campagne du
président la sécurité les armées la
justice ensuite il y a des ministères
qui font des efforts ministère de Bruno
Le Maire et moi-même Bercy et bien placé
pour le savoir puisque ça fait 20 ans
qu'il fait des efforts l'essentiel des
efforts pour l'État je rappelle que dans
le dernier quinquennat 2000 suppressions
de postes par an en moyenne à Bercy
continuera à faire des efforts mais un
rythme moins important que celui qu'on a
connu le ces dernières années parce que
nous devons évidemment garantir la bonne
tenue d'émission de Bercy mais
continuera à être exemplaire il y a par
ailleurs des ministères pour lesquels il
y aura moins de création nécessaire dans
les années à venir même si on va
continuer à créer des postes je pense à
l'éducation nationale où il y aura 500
000 élèves en moins dans nos écoles
collèges et lycées dans les cinq ans qui
viennent souviens qu'il y avait eu un
bon démographique et donc derrière une
baisse démographique on est dedans donc
500 000 élèves en moins on va continuer
à créer des postes mais y compris pour
continuer à améliorer le taux
d'encadrement on n'a pas besoin de créer
autant de postes qu'on en créé
auparavant on va continuer à le faire je
précise par ailleurs que derrière les
hausses d'effectifs publics que vous
avez noté l'an prochain il y a notamment
un enjeu de sincérisation budgétaire
puisque maintenant on met sous schéma
d'emploi de l'État les aesh parce
qu'avant c'était pas compté dans
l'emploi public c'était un peu caché
entre guillemets en tout cas c'était pas
compté dans notre schéma d'emploi on
considère que les aesh on les recrute on
fait tout pour que ça soit moins
précaire ils sont là pour durer puisque
c'est un enjeu d'accompagnement nos
élèves en situation de handicap c'est
une mesure de bonne gestion et de
sincérisation que de les passer sous
plafond de l'État Michel Castellane sur
la Corse vous l'avez rappelé il y a des
discussions importantes qui se tiennent
en ce moment avec notre collègue Gérald
Darmanin évidemment on y est très
attentifs et on apportera tout le
soutien nécessaire pour que ces
discussions se passent bien sur les
volets économiques et fiscaux il y a
notamment une réunion qui doit se tenir
fin octobre début novembre précisément
sur les questions économiques et
financières et notamment sur la
fiscalité vous avez mentionné l'article
9 qui fait référence à la suppression de
l'exonération temporaire de l'impôt sur
les sociétés en faveur des entreprises
créées en Corse dans certains secteur je
vais vous rassurer en confirmant qu'il
s'agit d'une mesure de nettoyage puisque
cette exonération ne s'applique plus
donc il n'y aura pas de perdant entre
guillemets c'est une mesure de nettoyage
de notre
fiscalité puisque c'est une mesure qui
est asservie mais qui aujourd'hui ne
sert plus mais on peut vous passer tous
les éléments vraiment pour vous rassurer
sur ce point-là et rassurer peut-être
des acteurs économiques locaux qui sont
inquiéterait c'était là Dupont sur la
pauvreté l'hébergement d'urgence je
rappelle que le coeur de notre politique
de lutte contre la pauvreté c'est bien
l'emploi vous connaissez vous partagez
notre stratégie on a taux de chômage au
plus bas depuis 15 ans c'est des
millions de Français qui ont retrouvé un
emploi donc qui sortent de la pauvreté
grâce à l'emploi sur
l'hébergement d'urgence
je veux rappeler que les crédits du
programme 177 progressent de 100
millions d'euros on finance les
revalorisations salariales pour les
métiers d'accompagnant mais aussi on
lance le deuxième plan logement d'abord
qui visera à favoriser le logement
adapté et l'accès direct au logement
plutôt que l'hébergement en unité
hôtelière
les crédits de la mission solidarité
progresse vous l'avez rappelé de 2,1
milliards d'euros c'est l'effet de la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
pour suivre l'inflation mais aussi de la
mise en œuvre au plus tard le premier
octobre 2023 comme vous l'avez voté cet
été de la décongalisation de la hache
qui est un progrès important monsieur
alisio sur le fait de caper la taxe
foncière moi je rappelle une chose c'est
que légalement les impôts locaux
fonciers sont revalorisés avec
l'inflation ça a toujours été le cas que
l'intégralité des associations d'élus
nous ont entre guillemets implorés de ne
pas revenir sur la règle légale
donc le texte ne prévoit pas de revenir
sur la règle légale ce que je constate
c'est qu'il y a débat sur ce sujet que
ce soit dans la majorité ou dans les
oppositions j'ai entendu notamment dans
les dialogues de Bercy Jean-René
Cazeneuve pour la majorité monsieur
decourson et d'autres pour les
oppositions qui ont interrogé ce
sujet-là donc j'imagine qu'il y aura un
débat parlementaire sur ce sujet là moi
je peux redire ce que j'ai dit c'est que
moi j'appelle évidemment les
collectivités à ne pas faire exploser
leur taux de fiscalité locale à ne pas
venir fissurer tous les efforts qui sont
faits pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat
des Français il y a par ailleurs des
collectivités qui peuvent tout à fait
baisser leur taux pour compenser la
revalorisation liée à l'inflation un
certain nombre de maires ont annoncé
qu'il le feraient monsieur lothiot vous
nous avez interrogé aussi sur la
fiscalité locale pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait un millésime de trois ans sur la
CVAE parce qu'en fait il y a pas de
bonne année de CVAE pour tout le monde
même quand vous avez au niveau national
une très bonne année de CVAE vous avez
des collectivités qui sont à leur point
bas et inversement quand vous avez ce
qui serait qualifié d'une mauvaise année
de CVAE au niveau national vous avez des
collectivités à leur point haut c'est
une ressource très volatile si je prends
un exemple le plus
spectaculaire c'est les collectivités
qui ont sur leur territoire une centrale
nucléaire qui est à l'arrêt pour cause
de maintenance prenez la commune de
Civaux par exemple ils avaient ils ont
cette année une recette de CVAE qui est
de 3,8 millions d'euros l'an prochain
ils auront 53000 euros
voilà passe de 3,8 millions à 53000
euros parce que la centrale nucléaire
est à l'arrêt ce qu'on donne avec la
compensation c'est une garantie une
visibilité sur l'avenir avec la garantie
que notre CVE ne baissera jamais pour
les collectivités locales c'est quand
même une très belle garantie qui est
donnée sur la territorialisation de la
dynamique oui on veut que la dynamique
de CV e soit territorialisée en gros
qu'un maire qui accueille une activité
économique sur son territoire puisse
continuer à dire à ces administrés que
c'est bon pour les recettes de la ville
ce qu'on a proposé c'est dans la copie
que vous recevez c'est de
territorialiser en se fondant sur les
bases de CFE qui est déjà l'un des
critères de territorialisation de la
CVAE d'affectation de la CVAE
plusieurs associations d'élus plusieurs
parlementaires aussi dans les dialogues
de Bercy nous ont dit que c'était pas
suffisant et qu'il fallait penser à
d'autres critères on est très ouverts
dans le cadre des débats sur le PLF
enrichir les critères sur la norme de
dépenses vous dites que ça remet en
cause d'autonomie des collectivités
locales la réponse est non les contrats
de Cahors eux-mêmes avaient été évalués
par le juge constitutionnel qui avait
considéré qu'il ne remettait pas en
cause l'autonomie des collectivités
locales là on est passé des contrats de
Cahors au contrat de confiance c'est
beaucoup moins on va dire mordant que
les contrats de Cahors donc ça veut pas
remettre en cause l'autonomie des
collectivités locales en revanche oui il
y a un mécanisme pour revenir à une
trajectoire de maîtrise des dépenses
s'il y a des dérapages et c'est normal
vous disiez c'est la même norme pour
tout le monde non c'est pas la même
norme pour tout le monde puisque en cas
de dérapage le mécanisme de retour vers
une trajectoire s'appliquera non pas à
toute collectivité mais à celles qui ont
un budget supérieur à 40 millions
d'euros c'est à dire qu'en gros c'est
les 500 plus grosses collectivités dans
notre pays qui sont visés par ce
dispositif monsieur Sala vous avez dit
quel changement après les dialogues de
berc je crois que dans mes réponses
depuis le début de cette audition j'ai
montré qu'un certain nombre de choses
avaient évolué que ce soit
l'actualisation des bases locatives qui
a été abandonnée puisque l'ensemble des
groupes dans les dialogues de Bercy nous
ont dit qu'il fallait revenir dessus car
suspendu en tout cas le temps de trouver
un meilleur une meilleure solution mais
en gros ça revenait à augmenter la
fiscalité sur les commerces de
centre-ville et abaisser celle des
hypermarchés en périphérie c'est quand
même pas tout à fait notre objectif
quand on fait action cœur de ville et
tout pour redynamiser les centres-villes
donc on suspense a été demandé dans les
dialogues de Bercy il y a eu des idées
qui ont été émises notamment sur
l'abondement des dotations de
péridotation on le reprend 210 millions
d'euros et des propositions qui ont été
faites pour mieux protéger la forêt
sanctuariser les effectifs de l'ONF on
le reprend alors que des suppressions
étaient prévues
une incitation fiscale pour les
propriétaires à replanter dans la forêt
on le reprend des fonds pour accompagner
les communes forestières victimes de
scolith on le reprend on a prévu une
enveloppe en plus un débat sur la
qualité de la dépense publique on
prévoit une accroche dans LPFP pour
avoir un vrai article suite au débat
qu'on a eu dans les dialogues de Bercy
moi je constate que ça a été utile pour
notre projet de loi de finance c'est
plusieurs semaines de travail qui sont
je pense utile pour notre pays infinie
et pour terminer Monsieur bencheck sur
l'action extérieure de l'État oui il y a
une hausse de 187 millions d'euros dont
63 millions de masses salariales des
crédits de la mission hors transfert
notamment pour financer un certain
nombre de priorités identifiées en 2022
l'immobilier la sécurisation renforcer
les moyens de la diplomatie culturelle
et d'influence c'est 47 millions d'euros
en plus pour ce qui est des Français à
l'étranger les moyens dédiés aux aides à
la scolarité pour les enfants scolarisés
dans le réseau de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger seront maintenus
notamment pour ce qui est de réarmer la
diplomatie après un renforcement des
effectifs en administration centrale en
LFI 2022 la mission bénéficie d'un
schéma d'emploi de plus 100 ETTP en 2023
afin de répondre à ses besoins
prioritaires tels que le renforcement de
notre présence dans l'Indo Pacifique
nous avons eu un certain nombre de
nominations importantes ce matin en
conseil des ministres d'un point de vue
diplomatique et notre capacité d'analyse
politique dans les postes les plus
exposés la sécurisation des emprises
diplomatiques qui est un enjeu très fort
pour nous aussi et le renforcement de la
cybersécurité ou encore la lutte contre
la manipulation de l'information voilà
je terminerai en disant que m'a été
indiqué en venant ici qu'il y avait une
spécialité pour les ministres du Budget
c'est d'offrir une spécialité locale à
aux député je le dis et c'est pas une
critique contre ma circonscription il y
a assez peu de spécialités locales à
Issy-les-Moulineaux et avant même si on
a des artisans de talent et donc vous
trouverez des macarons à votre
disposition à la sortie de cette salle
voilà j'allais le préciser quand même
que vous aviez offert des macarons juste
merci messieurs les ministres pour ces
réponses on se retrouve demain à 17h15
pour l'audition du gouverneur de la
Banque de France
que je termine le 28 à 9h30 pour
l'audition de Pierre Moscovici pour le
Haut Conseil finance publique et à 16
éditions on continue les auditions des
associations de communes et des
départements et des EPT voilà merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le ministre